Hey, Will, what's your middle name? My middle name? Yeah, quick. It's Emerson. That's right. You don't sound sure. It is Emerson. No, no, no.
嘿，威尔，你的中间名是什么？我的中间名？对，快点。是埃默森。没错。你听起来不太确定。就是埃默森。不，不，不。
I'm not. I just thought that you knew. I thought you knew everything about me. No, I didn't know. I don't. Sean, your middle name? Patrick. Patrick.
我不是不确定。我只是以为你知道。我以为你了解我的一切。不，我不知道。我不了解。肖恩，你的中间名？帕特里克。帕特里克。
Really? Oh, yeah, you're right. Sean Patrick Hayes. Yeah. And JB, what's yours? Let me guess yours. It's something, it's very, it's like. Here it comes.
真的吗？哦，对，你是对的。肖恩·帕特里克·海耶斯。没错。那JB，你的呢？让我猜猜你的。是某个词，非常，就像是。来了。
Hurtful. No. Careful. It's my dad's first name. So if he's listening, careful. Oh, missing? No. No, I know what it is.
伤人。不。小心点。是我爸爸的名字。所以如果他在听的话，小心点。哦，错过了？不。不，我知道是什么。
I know what it is. It's. That's Sean, you dick. It's Kent. My dad's name is Kent. Kent. Kent. You can't ever forget it. So you're Kent. I know what it is. I know what it is. It's... That's Sean, you dick. My dad's name is Kent. Kent.
我知道是什么。是。那是肖恩，你这个混蛋。是肯特。我爸爸的名字是肯特。肯特。肯特。你永远忘不了它。所以你是肯特。我知道是什么。我知道是什么。是……那是肖恩，你这个混蛋。我爸爸的名字是肯特。肯特。
Kent. You can't ever forget it. So you're Kent Jason Bateman? No, Jason Kent Bateman. Dumb fuck. Middle name. Alright, welcome to Smart List. I never showed you this video. I have a video to show you. Hang on. Open the book.
肯特。你永远忘不了它。所以你是肯特·杰森·贝特曼？不，杰森·肯特·贝特曼。笨蛋。中间名。好了，欢迎来到《SmartLess》。我还没给你看过这个视频。我有个视频要给你看。等等。打开书。
Oh wait, here it is. Oh yeah, have you seen this? Is that you and Scotty? God, I hope that's you and Scotty. Yeah, it is. Is it? Yeah. Why, where, when? Listener, we have Sean and Scotty
哦等等，在这儿。哦对了，你看过这个吗？那是你和斯科蒂吗？天哪，我希望那是你和斯科蒂。对，是。是吗？对。为什么，在哪，什么时候？听众们，我们有肖恩和斯科蒂
in one of these self-propelled locomotives going down a track. Yeah, it's awesome. It's called Rail. Redwood Forest. Like a little paddle boat you'd ride in a lake on. Yeah, it's through the forest. It's called Railbiking.
在这些自推进的机车里沿着轨道行驶。对，太棒了。这叫轨道自行车。红木森林。就像你在湖里骑的那种小脚踏船。对，它穿过森林。这叫轨道骑行。
Where was that? Was that on Second Honeymoon? That was up north, north of San Francisco. We went last weekend, was it? Or two weekends ago or something like that. Why were you guys up there messing around on the trail? Because I saw it like on Instagram or something, this rail bike that you just pedaled on the railroad tracks.
那是在哪？是在第二次蜜月旅行吗？那是在北部，旧金山以北。我们上周末去的，还是上上周末？或者类似的时间。你们为什么在那儿在小路上瞎逛？因为我在Instagram还是什么地方看到了，这种你可以在铁轨上踩的轨道自行车。
So you're like Scottie Pack and overnight pack? Yeah, we just went up there, we just did it. We gotta do this? Yeah, it's amazing. I can't imagine being as spontaneous and happy-go-lucky as that. Just like you're scrolling through it. Well, it was planned a little bit.
所以你们就像斯科蒂那样打包过夜？对，我们就是去了，我们就做了。我们得去试试这个？对，太棒了。我无法想象能像那样随性又无忧无虑。就像你刷着手机看到的那样。嗯，其实还是稍微计划了一下。
But it still came from just scrolling through Instagram. I'm like, hey, that looks fun. Hun, what are you doing next weekend? Why not? I mean, there's a whole world out there. You know what I mean? I just feel like it's so disruptive to pick up and leave the place there where you're settled.
但它确实源于刷Instagram。我就想，嘿，那看起来很有趣。亲爱的，你下周末做什么？为什么不呢？我的意思是，外面有一个广阔的世界。你明白我的意思吗？我只是觉得离开你安顿下来的地方去别处太折腾了。
I just have zero wanderlust. I'm not proud of it, but. You don't, huh? No. But you love the outdoors and stuff, don't you? It was so beautiful from the inside of an air-conditioned car. I was saying to you when we were flying in New York,
我完全没有那种漫游癖。我不以此为荣，但是。你没有，是吗？没有。但你喜欢户外活动之类的，不是吗？从空调车里看出去真是太美了。我跟你说过，当我们飞往纽约的时候，
I was like, I point out the window, I go, there's a whole world out there. Yeah, exactly. I wanna get it, I was saying to somebody yesterday, I wanna get into the world, it's all I wanna do. Wouldn't it be fun to all go, the three of us, and our significant others to go, like do like an adventure like that,
我指着窗外说，外面有一个广阔的世界。对，没错。我想去看看，我昨天跟某人说，我想去看看这个世界，这就是我想做的一切。如果我们三个人，还有我们的另一半，一起去进行那样的一次冒险，不是很有趣吗？
just for like the weekend? Yeah, but can it be higher end than paddle boarding down a rail? It's not paddle boarding. Yes, we can do something a little more significant. You know, one of the things that we should talk about, but probably not on the podcast, but I'm going to do it anyway, is Sean and I were talking with the ladies, i.e. your wife, JB,
就为了周末？对，但能不能比在铁轨上踩脚踏车更高级一点？那不是踩脚踏车。是的，我们可以做点更有意义的事。你知道，有一件事我们应该谈谈，但可能不该在播客上谈，但我还是要说，就是肖恩和我当时在和女士们聊天，也就是你的妻子，JB，
and my significant other, Alessandra, and the ladies. We can include Scottie in there as a second guy. Well, Scottie was there too, and then our other female friend who's an advisor to the podcast, so has a lot of opinions. She, she, she. Amanda.
还有我的另一半，亚历山德拉，以及女士们。我们可以把斯科蒂也算作第二个男人。嗯，斯科蒂也在那儿，还有我们另一位女性朋友，她是播客的顾问，所以有很多意见。她，她，她。阿曼达。
No, no, no. No, the other one. Oh, that person, yes. And I said, I said, you know, we oughta go to, because they want us to come, then we can talk to our buddy, Mitch Rose, we oughta go to Australia at Christmas, which is their summer, which I've never done,
不，不，不。不，是另外一个。哦，那个人，是的。我说，我说，你知道，我们应该去，因为她们想让我们去，然后我们可以和我们的哥们米奇·罗斯谈谈，我们应该在圣诞节去澳大利亚，那是她们的夏天，我从来没去过，
and do the tour and do like Sydney Opera House. I've never been. I would like to do that, but can we go, can we do, we did skiing last year, can we go beach this year? So this is what I was gonna say, we go there and then we do, we did skiing last year. Can we go beach this year? So this is what I was gonna say. We go there and then we do the beach. They don't have any beaches in Australia.
去旅游，去看看悉尼歌剧院之类的。我从来没去过。我想去，但我们能不能，我们去年去滑雪了，今年能不能去海滩？所以我正要说的是，我们去那儿，然后我们做，我们去年去滑雪了。今年能不能去海滩？所以我正要说的是。我们去那儿，然后去海滩。澳大利亚没有海滩。
They don't have beaches. Are you crazy? No, it's all landlocked. And we go to like the Gold Coast somewhere and we do like a week of like incredible beach. Why do we have to be working when we're vacationing? We do a little bit of both. But my thing, but Will, my thing is you get the beach here where in, on the West Coast,
她们没有海滩。你疯了吗？不，那是内陆国家。我们去黄金海岸之类的地方，待上一周，享受不可思议的海滩。为什么我们度假时非得工作？我们可以两者兼顾。但我的意思是，威尔，我的意思是你在西海岸就能去海滩，
wouldn't you want to go somewhere different? Without the 17 hour flight. What beach? What beach? What do you mean? There's, have you looked at a map? It's all, we're on the edge of the water. You mean the California beaches? I'm talking about tropical beaches.
难道你不想去个不一样的地方吗？不用坐17小时的飞机。什么海滩？什么海滩？你什么意思？有，你看过地图吗？全是，我们在水边。你是说加州的海滩？我说的是热带海滩。
First of all, Sean, nice try. You might as well still live in Chicago. Okay? Cause you go, you go from your fucking house to fucking Larchmont and that's right Give me a fucking you could live it could be anywhere. You might as well move into a mall. I mean Inside okay, then you and Scottie can do the fucking laps to the food court What I'm suggesting is I'm so white it's true
首先，肖恩，算了吧。你还不如继续住在芝加哥。好吗？因为你从你那该死的房子去该死的拉奇蒙特，那真是……给我个该死的……你住哪都一样。你还不如搬进商场里住。我的意思是，在里面，好，那你和斯科蒂可以去美食广场跑圈。我建议的是，我太白了，这是真的。
We go to Australia or somewhere like that and we go somewhere that we wouldn't normally go That's out of our comfort zone. That's why and then we do a full beach experience. I actually would like that I would like to I've never been on I love I love Australia like I can't even we do have to go somewhere But but wait guys listen, I don't want to keep our fancy guests waiting So rude to talk about I know the gas but you guys she's sitting in there waiting from overseas She's in the UK right now. What? Yes, but you'd never know with her flawless American accent that she does. She can act,
我们去澳大利亚或类似的地方，去一个我们通常不会去的地方。那超出了我们的舒适区。这就是为什么，然后我们进行一次完整的海滩体验。我其实会喜欢那样。我喜欢，我喜欢澳大利亚，我甚至……我们确实得去某个地方。但，但等等，伙计们，听着，我不想让我们的贵宾久等。谈论这些太粗鲁了。我知道嘉宾，但你们，她坐在那儿等着，从海外来的。她现在在英国。什么？是的，但你绝对听不出她那完美的美国口音。她会演戏，
she can sing. Boy, can she sing. Wow. And in her most recent film. You wrote that part too. I wrote all of this. And in her most recent film, she can even swim the English channel, which I tried to watch last night, but the links they send you, I forget it. This effervescent young lady's middle name is Jazz. Remember we were just talking about our middle names? And she has been a hot ticker. Annette Benning or Jodie Foster, which one?
她会唱歌。天哪，她真会唱。哇。在她最近的电影里。你也写了那部分。我写了所有这些。在她最近的电影里，她甚至能游过英吉利海峡，我昨晚试着看，但他们发给你的链接，我忘了。这位充满活力的年轻女士的中间名是爵士。记得我们刚才在谈论我们的中间名吗？她近十年来一直是电影界的红人，从她加入史上最大的电影系列之一开始。显然她在多邻国上的法语分数也相当令人印象深刻。她就是光芒四射的黛西·雷德利。
Nope, it's not either. And she has been a hot ticket in the film industry for almost a decade, starting when she joined one of the biggest movie franchises of all time. Apparently her Duolingo score in French is pretty impressive too. It's the radiant Daisy Ridley.
黛西·雷德利！我认识黛西一点点。嗨，黛西！天哪，那儿几点了？6点27分。没那么疯狂，才6点27分。你以为她在火星上吗？黛西·雷德利，欢迎来到《SmartLess》。我很高兴能和你交谈并见到你。我是你的超级粉丝。太奇怪了。我听过很多次，现在我像，我在这儿。你真的听过吗？不，你没有。当然。抱歉，听起来有点像
Daisy Ridley! I know Daisy a tiny bit. Hi Daisy! Oh my god, what time is it there? It's 6.27. It's not that crazy, it's 6.27. What do you think, she's on Mars? Daisy Ridley, welcome to Smart Listen. I'm so excited to talk to you and meet you. I'm a massive fan. It's so weird. I've listened to it so much and I'm like, I'm here. Have you really? No you haven't. Of course. I'm sorry it's sounding a little bit like
今早的早间广播。我们太爱聊天了。抱歉。我们会冷静下来的。我们会冷静下来的。黛西，你觉得我们应该在圣诞节带家人去澳大利亚吗？我十天前刚从澳大利亚回来，在那儿拍电影。玩得很开心。强烈推荐。真的吗？那你现在在英国做什么？你住在那儿吗？我住这儿，是的。
drive-time radio this morning. We're a little too chatty. Sorry. We'll calm down. We'll calm down. Daisy, do you think we should go to Australia for Christmas with our families? I got back from Australia ten days ago, shooting a movie there. Had a great time. Can't recommend it enough. Really? So what are you doing in England right now? Do you live there? I live here, yeah.
你是在那儿长大的。好吧。所以你现在在家里很舒服？我在家里很舒服。你是在那儿长大的？你是在那儿长大的，好吧。所以你现在在家里很舒服？我在家里很舒服。我是在这儿长大的。除了工作，我其实从没在别的地方住过。我真是个宅女。所以，我爱伦敦。
And you grew up there. Alright. So you're cozy at home right now? I'm cozy at home. And you grew up there? You grew up there, all right. So you're cozy at home right now? I'm cozy at home. I grew up here. I've never actually lived anywhere else bar for work. I'm a real homebody. So like, I love London.
我总是喜欢——你在那儿找到住的好地方了吗，肖恩？我知道，惠特比酒店很棒。对吧，有人吗？没有。我喜欢俱乐部。但伦敦很棒，我爱它。我总是想知道那会是什么样，
I always like- You find a nice place to stay there, Sean? I do know, the Whitby hotels are amazing. Right, anybody? No. I like the club. But London is great, I love it. I always wondered like what it would be,
你欣赏它就像我们欣赏它一样吗？还是你只是觉得，那是大本钟，那是那个那个，我不，你知道，历史悠久，美丽动人。是的，每次我经过议会大厦，我就想，哦，然后我走进城里，公园很美。
like do you appreciate it like we appreciate it or are you just like, there's the big bang, there's the blah blah blah, I don't, you know, the history and it's so old and beautiful and gorgeous. Yeah, every time I go past the Houses of Parliament, I'm like, oh, and then I walk into town, parks are beautiful.
我的意思是，伦敦的夏天真的很棒。所以我现在很高兴能在这儿。你有没有想过住在别的地方？我和我丈夫在封锁前几个月打算搬到洛杉矶住几个月。所以我们订了地方，什么都准备好了。我们只是想看看住几个月是什么感觉。试一试。
I mean, summer in London is really nice. So I'm very happy to be here right now. Have you ever desired to live somewhere else? Me and my husband were gonna move to LA for a few months just before lockdown. So we had like a place booked and everything. We were just gonna see what it was like for a few months. Try it on.
然后就封锁了。现在，你为什么要试一试？你是不是受到了……现在你为什么要试一试？你是不是受到了生活中大人们的压力，说，能不能请你离制片厂近一点？不，完全没有。这只是，我想，一种好奇心。然后没成，我们就没去。但我丈夫，他是基于真实故事，显然……他的名字是汤姆，他的姓是……
And then lockdown. Now, why were you gonna try it on? Were you getting. Now why were you going to try it on? Were you getting pressure from the adults in your life that say, can you please be closer to the studios? No, not at all. It was just, I guess, a curiosity. And then it didn't happen and then we didn't. But my husband, who is based on a true story, obviously... And his name is Tom and his last name is...
最棒的。他的名字是汤姆，他的姓是？最棒的。贝特曼。是的，我的意思是，这名字听起来不顺口吗？汤姆·贝特曼。所以因为那个节目，他现在住在那儿。嗯，他快要第二次住在那儿了。所以这是两全其美。那你打算怎么办？
The best. The his name is Tom and his last name is? The best. Bademan. Yeah, I mean, does that just not roll right off the tongue? Tom Bademan. So because of that show, he's now lived there. Well, he's about to live there for the second time. So it's best of both worlds. So then what are you going to do?
你是要加入他，还是会忙于另一个项目？你们是怎么处理这些事情的？我们尽力而为。那挺好的。我们尽力了。那挺好的，因为《年轻女子与海》现在有幸在影院上映了。
Are you going to join him or are you gonna be busy on another project? How do you guys work all that stuff? We do what we can. And that's pretty nice. We do our best. That's pretty nice because Young Woman in the Sea now wonderfully has a theatrical release.
所以我可以在洛杉矶为它做些工作。所以我们会一起在那儿。那太好了。然后，是的。但我们处理得很好。他在这方面做得很好。它叫《基于真实故事》。我知道肖恩和威尔可能在你的排队名单里。去享受吧。
So I get to do some work for that in LA. So we'll be there together. That's so nice. And then, yeah. But we work it out pretty well. He's so good on that. It is called Based on a True Story. I know Sean and Will is probably in your queue there. Go ahead and enjoy that.
谢谢。在孔雀台（Peacock）上。你在这部剧里没股份吗？哦是的，当然，我当然有。哦，你有吗？好吧，为了完全披露，给我们解释一下。嗯，如果再多几个人看，我会得到相当大的提升，所以我们只差两个了。
Thank you. It's on the Peacock. And you've got no skit in the game on this one? Oh yes, sure, no, sure I do. Oh, do you? Well, explain to us just for full disclosure. Well I get quite a bump if a couple more people start watching it, so we're just two away.
等等，你是制片人吗？他是执行制片人，是的。哦，我不知道。而且我没，听着，这是你的嘉宾吗？我不是在试图增加我的收视率。不，好吧，我们得看。你一直对黛西眨眼，好像在提示她。那是抽动，敏感点。
Wait, are you producing it? He's the executive producer of it, yeah. Oh I didn't know that. And I didn't, listen, is this your guest? I am not trying to get to my viewership. No, well we have to watch it. You kept winking at Daisy as if like prompt her. That's a tick, be sensitive.
那是抽动。好吧。现在听着，黛西，敏感点。那是抽动。现在听着，黛西，告诉我们关于在那儿长大的事，因为你，首先，一个家庭五个女孩。哦是的，但我两个同父异母的姐姐大很多，因为我父母之间有年龄差距，所以我们没和她们一起长大，但我们三个在一起还是很多。那很多，那很多。
That's a tick. Okay. Now listen, Daisy, be sensitive. That's a tick. Now listen, Daisy, tell us about growing up there because you, first of all, five girls in one family. Oh yes, but my two half-sisters are a lot older because there's an age gap with my parents, so we didn't grow up with them, but three of us was still a lot. That's a lot, That's a lot.
那很多。父亲是摄影师，母亲在银行工作，没别人有进入这个行业的念头。嗯，我妈妈其实在图片宣传部门工作了很长时间。我想她参与过《老友记》。她参与过一些很酷的项目。哦真的吗？她在《老友记》里做了什么？
That's a lot. And father was a photographer, mother worked at a bank, nobody else kind of had the bug to get into the business. Well my mom actually worked in picture publicity for a long time. I think worked on Friends. She worked on some really cool stuff. Oh really? What did she do with Friends?
嗯，她是第四频道的图片宣传员。她参与过一些很酷的项目。她在《老友记》里做了什么？她是第四频道的图片宣传员。所以当那些大节目播出时，她在处理照片。那个节目太有共鸣了，因为我们都知道那种感觉：当你的工作是个笑话，你破产了，你的爱情生活死气沉沉。你觉得你总是卡在二档。那不是你的日子，你的周，你的月，甚至你的年。我们能停一下吗？威尔，你熟悉那些歌词，因为你虔诚地看了那个节目？不，那首歌无处不在。
Well she was the picture publicist at Channel 4. She worked on some really cool stuff. What did she do with Friends? She was the picture publicist at Channel 4. So when all those big shows were going on and she was doing the pictures. That show was so related because we all knew that thing of when your job's a joke, you're broke, your love life's DOA. You feel like you're always stuck in second gear. It hasn't been your day, your week, your month, or even your year. Can we hold there for a second? So Will, you're familiar with those lyrics because you watched that show religiously? No, that song is omnipresent.
那是90年代的。不是。无法逃避。不，不，不。只有当你虔诚地看那个节目时才无法逃避，这是我关于你了解到的一个大发现，你是个隐藏的《老友记》粉丝。我想说隐藏，我爱《老友记》。我爱《老友记》。
It was in the 90s. It's not. Inescapable. No, no, no. It's only inescapable if you watch the show religiously and this is a big, big thing I'm learning about you is that you're a closet friends fan. I wanna say closet, I love friends. I love the friends.
黛西，你也爱《老友记》，对吧？别阻止我。我确实爱《老友记》，是的。是的，不。所有的英国人都爱《老友记》。我爱所有的《老友记》，我爱这个节目，我爱我们的朋友。我还没看，我很尴尬地说
Daisy, you love friends too, right? Don't stop me burning. I do love friends, yeah. Yeah, no. All the Brits love friends. I love all the friends and I love the show and I love our friends. I haven't watched, I'm embarrassed to say
我其实没看过很多，但我知道那首歌，因为它到处都是。但那是你的铃声，我想。不，但我以前在女孩们面前唱过。我对詹和冈恩做过。就像，我知道，我理解你，你知道，你的工作是个笑话，你破产了，你的爱情生活死气沉沉。然后她说，滚开。抱歉，黛西。
I haven't actually watched a ton of the show, but I know that song because it was everywhere. But that's your ringtone, I guess. No, but I have dropped that on the girls before. I have done that to Jen and Gunn. Like, I know, I feel you, you know, your job's a joke, you're broke, your love life's DOA, And she's like, fuck off. I'm sorry Daisy.
等等，等等，黛西，我们回去。所以你妈妈在宣传部门工作，可能为第四频道做过一些事。那么你是哪一刻想，你就像，妈妈，我需要做那个。天哪。我现在不能那样做了。你做了，你做了。
Wait, wait Daisy, let's go back. So your mom worked in publicity, maybe did some stuff for Channel 4 or something. But so what was the moment you go, you're like, mommy, I need to do that. Oh my God. I can't do that nowadays. You did, you did.
妈妈。是的，第一次是什么时候？嗯，我在小学。你现在不能那样做了。你做了。你做了。我年纪。是的，第一次是什么时候？嗯，我在小学。我稍微有点调皮。什么？我们过去常去，因为三个女孩，你想成为——这是特林公园学校，还是在特林公园之前？
Mommy. Yeah, what was the first time? Well, I was at primary school. You can't do that nowadays. You did. You did. I'm age. Yeah, what was the first time? Well, I was at primary school. I was slightly misbehaving. What? And we used to go, because three girls, you wanna be- Is this the Tring Park school, or is this before Tring Park?
这是在特林公园之前。哦，当然。因为，伙计们，你们要知道，特林公园，它看起来像《唐顿庄园》。简直不可思议。哦，是的。我不敢相信你在那儿上学。哦，是的，它简直是，而且我是个超级哈利·波特迷。
This is before Tring Park. Oh, sure. Because, guys, just so you know, Tring Park, it looks like Downton Abbey. It's like unbelievable. Oh, yeah. I can't believe you went to school there. Oh, yeah, it was literally, and I'm a huge Harry Potter fan.
它简直就是哈利·波特。我爱它。我小时候在学校很淘气。然后我妈妈，为了让我们在暑假有事做，常把我们送到这个音乐营，孩子们会去，我想就像你们的夏令营。我在那儿有个朋友去了寄宿学校。我就想，寄宿学校听起来太棒了。
It was literally Harry Potter. I love it. I was quite naughty at school as a child. And then my mom, to keep us busy in the summer holidays, used to send us to this music thing where kids would go and, I guess sort of like camp for you guys. And I had a friend there who went to boarding school. I was like, boarding school sounds amazing.
她觉得如果我忙起来，我会表现得更好。所以我去试镜了这个表演艺术学校，虽然我从没真正做过表演艺术，然后最终在那儿从9岁待到了18岁。哇。所以在那个过程中，爱上了所有的表演艺术。太棒了。能问问你那种调皮是什么样的吗？
And she thought if I was busy, I would behave better. And so I auditioned for this performing arts school, having never really done performing arts, and then ended up staying there from nine till 18. Wow. So over the course of that time, fell in love with all of the performing arts. That's amazing. Can I ask you what your flavor of misbehavior was?
嗯，我的意思是，如果我当时还很小，我不至于那么坏，但如果我没那么忙，我就会开始分散其他孩子的注意力之类的。用幽默还是朝他们扔东西？我不知道。替朋友问的。我有几次被劝退的经历，可以这么说。我确实混得挺乱的。
Well, I mean, I can't have been that bad if I was fairly young, but just if I wasn't busy enough, I would start distracting other kids and that sort of stuff. With humor or throwing shit at them? I don't know. Asking for a friend. I had a few different encouragements not to return, shall we say. And I kind of mixed it up quite a bit.
我去了寄宿学校，我没被开除。我做这个区分。我是被劝退的。是的。很好。她们就是那样。我的第一份工作，我被劝退了，第二周就没去了。
I went to boarding school and I was not kicked out. I make this distinction. I was asked not to return. Yeah. Very good. That's what they're like. My first ever job actually, I was asked not to return for the second week.
那真是，老实说，太令人沮丧了。真的吗？等等，等等，发生了什么？嗯，最糟糕的是，那就像一个排练剧本的工作坊。甚至不是剧本。就像剧本朗读之类的。甚至没录音。什么？是的，所以我们做了两周的工作坊，周五她们就说，你
It was this, it was honestly fucking soul-crushing. Really? Wait, wait, wait, what happened? Well the worst thing was, it was like a workshop thing to do a play. It wasn't even a play. It was like a table read or whatever. It wasn't even recorded. What? Yeah, so we were doing the workshop for two weeks and on the Friday they were like, you
下周不用来了。天哪。太可怕了。显然，我从工作中请了假，因为当时我在酒吧工作，我想，天哪，因为我表现太差了，老实说。真的吗？不，我不相信。不，说真的。
don't need to come back next week. Oh my God. It was hideous. And obviously, like, I had taken time out of my job because at the time I was working at a pub and I thought, oh my God, because I was terrible, honestly. Really? No, I don't believe that. No, seriously.
她们说，你对这个毫无贡献。你在酒吧工作表现好吗？我其实表现不错，是的。真的吗？那是倒酒，做那个，叫什么来着？生啤。倒品脱。生啤，是的。
They were like, you bring nothing to this. Were you good at working at the pub? I actually was, yeah. Really? Was that pouring the, doing the, what's it called? The draft. Doing the pints. The draft, yeah.
做那个，然后你把上面的泡沫刮掉？倒得很好的，其实我不该那么说。我的意思是，在伦敦倒品脱，你不会做那个动作。哦，为什么？或者你只是让它溢出来。我不知道。你有级联。但你表现很好。
Doing that and then you do the little haircut off the top of it? A well poured, actually I shouldn't say that. I mean, pouring pints in London, you don't do that thing. Oh, why? Or you just let it drip over. I don't know. You've got a cascade. But you were good.
如果有人想进来喝杯啤酒，你可以很好地为他们服务，然后让他们离开。喝杯啤酒。是的。我最近其实经历了一件很奇怪的事。我在巴黎的第几区的一家酒店为我几年前拍的一部小电影做宣传。早餐时一个男人走过来，他说，你是黛西吗？
If somebody wanted to come in for a cheeky pint, you could just serve them up nicely and then send them on their way. Cheeky pint. Yeah. I actually had a very strange thing recently. I was in the,th arrondissement of Paris in a hotel doing some press for a tiny movie I made a couple years ago. And a guy at breakfast comes over and he goes, are you Daisy?
我说，是的，你很面熟。我以前在酒吧服务过他。哦，哇。他是个摄影师，写过一本关于鲍伊的书，在那儿宣传那本书。他说，我最后一次见你时，你正在给我倒品脱，说哦，我有个试镜，希望顺利，那是《星球大战》。那是我最后一次见他。
I was like, yeah, you're so familiar. I used to serve him at the pub. Oh, wow. And he's a photographer, did a book on Bowie and was there promoting the book. And he was like, literally the last time I saw you you were pouring me a pint saying oh I have this audition hopefully it will go well and it was Star Wars. And that was the last time I saw him.
太疯狂了。什么是鲍伊？大卫·鲍伊。哦，鲍伊。鲍伊。鲍伊。很多英国人说鲍伊。哦，我没听见。
That's crazy. What's Bowie? David Bowie. Oh Bowie. Bowie. Bowie. A lot of Brits say Bowie. Oh I didn't hear that.
我是来为你翻译的，黛西。等等，这就是我想问你的，黛西。等等，这就是我想问的。你为了《星球大战》退学了，对吧？我从大学退学了，是的。但我的意思是，并不是说你必须注册并在校园里那种。对。你可以线上做之类的。是的。
I'm here to translate for you Daisy. Wait so that's what I want to ask for you, Daisy. Wait, so that's what I want to ask. You dropped out of college to take Star Wars, right? I dropped out of university, yeah. But I mean, it wasn't like you had to be enrolled and be on campus sort of thing. Right. You could do it online or something. Yes.
但有任何犹豫吗？那不是特朗普大学吧？有集体诉讼，所以你可以参与。在那么年轻的时候接受那个角色有任何犹豫吗？因为在学校或者其他什么，担心它可能会……你甚至想过它会永远改变你的生活方式吗？还是你更像，让我滚出这儿，我想工作？
But was there any hesitation at all? It wasn't Trump Trump University was it? There is a class action so you can get involved Was there any hesitation at all in Accepting that role at such a young age because being in school or whatever for fear that it might like did you even think about my Changed your way of life forever or were you more like, get me the hell out of here, I want to work?
你知道我的意思吗？你有没有想过它会多大程度上改变你的生活？嗯，JJ太有说服力了，你知道吗？我的意思是，你进入那些眼睛，那个漩涡，JJ会说服你做任何事，对吧？你融化了，你融化了。我其实有一条他发的搞笑短信。
You know what I mean? Like did you ever think about like how much it would change your life? Well JJ is so convincing, you know? I mean you get inside those eyes, that vortex there, JJ will talk you into anything, right? You melt, you melt. I actually have a hilarious text from him.
最棒的。他过去常对我说，你的眼睛太大了。所以我去年看我做的一些东西，我的眼睛在里面太大了。我拍了张照片发给他，他真的给我发了一条生日短信，上面全是我的眼睛。太搞笑了。
The best. He used to say to me, your eyes are so big. So I was watching something I did last year and my eyes are so massive in the thing. I took a picture and sent it to him and he's literally sent me a birthday text with just like my eyes everywhere. That's funny.
当时完全没有犹豫。我渴望那个角色，从第一次试镜开始已经等了七个月。所以我当时想，给我个机会。你试镜了七个月才得到肯定的答复？是的，我在七个月的时间里进行了多次试镜。是的。天哪。
There was zero hesitation now. I was desperate for the role and had been waiting seven months from my first audition. So I was like, give me a chance. You auditioned seven months before you got the yes? Yeah, I did a number of auditions over a seven-month period. Yeah. Oh my God.
你有没有告诉酒吧，我不能再工作了，因为我现在要拍《星球大战》了。再见。我说，我找到工作了。所以我得走了，再见。真的吗？走，再见。是的，但我没说。他们说，你为什么要用
And did you just tell the pub, I can't work anymore because I'm now I'm gonna be doing Star Wars. See you guys later. I said, I've got a job. So I'm gonna have to go bye-bys. Really? Go bye-bys. Yeah, but then I didn't tell. Did they say, why are you speaking to us
四岁小孩的语气跟我们说话？就像他们没说。是的。得说再见。他们说，你怎么了？是的，不，我只是说，哦，我刚找到工作，我得走了。反正几个月内没人知道发生了什么。
like a four-year-old? Like they didn't say. Yeah. Have to make bye-bys. They were like, what's wrong with you? Yeah, no, I was just like, oh, I just got a job, I have to go. And no one knew what was going on for a few months anyway.
除了家人，我没告诉任何人。那个酒吧在城里的什么地方，以防他们在听？在西伯恩公园的联合酒馆。联合酒馆在西伯恩公园。为什么？为什么？你知道它吗？你要去参观吗？我两周后要去那儿。当我过去的时候，我要去替黛西打个招呼。顺便说一句，那是个非常漂亮的酒吧。就在运河边。就在波托贝洛旁边。是的。
I didn't tell anyone by my family. What part of town was that pub in just in case they're listening? It's the Union Tavern in Westbourne Park. Union Tavern in Westbourne Park. Why? Why? Do you know it? Are you going to go visit it? I'm going to go there in two weeks. When I go over there, I'm going to go say hi for Daisy. By the way, it's a really gorgeous pub. It's right on the canal. It's right by Portobello. Yeah.
我喜欢周六的波托贝洛。在周六。我一生中见过的最有趣的事情之一是一个男人，我们周六走在波托贝洛路上。谁是“我们”？谁是“我们”？我想大概是查皮和我。是的，就是这样。
I love Portobello on a Saturday. On a Saturday. One of the funniest things I've ever seen in my life was a guy, we were walking down Portobello Road on a Saturday. Who's we? Who's we? I guess it was Chappie and me probably. Yeah, there we go.
明白了。但是，因为他住在皇后公园，所以我们只是在走路。不，我知道。只需要再提一次查皮。我知道。所以这是我的朋友，马克·查佩尔，查皮。他们知道他是播客的朋友。那是两个。那是三个。是的。所以我们走着，马克·查佩尔，查佩尔。他们知道他是播客的朋友。那是两个，那是三个。
Got it. But, because he lives up in Queens Park and so we're just walking. No, I know. Just need to get Chappie in one more time. I know. And so this is my friend, Mark Chappell Chappie. They know he's a friend of the podcast. That's two. That's three. Yep. And so we're walking along, Mark Chappell Chappell. They know he's a friend of the podcast. That's two, that's three.
是的。所以我们走着，看到一个男人，美丽的周六，我们看到一个男人开着一辆橙色，像橙色冰沙颜色的兰博基尼，敞篷的。你知道那些，你知道那条路在周六有多挤，对吧？就像你可以，还有那些红绿灯，
Yep. And so we're walking along and we see a guy, beautiful Saturday, and we see a guy in like an orange, like an orange sherbert colored Lamborghini with the top down. And you know those, you know that road is like so packed on a Saturday, right? Like you can, and those stoplights,
就在你开始进入波托贝洛路之前。这个男人来了，他在红绿灯前开着这辆橙色的车，每个人都在看，然后绿灯亮了。他猛踩油门，就像，呜，呜！他只有大约70码的距离，下一个灯又是红灯。他不得不停下。每个人都集体嘲笑这个男人的脸。
like just before you start getting down into Portobello Road. And this guy comes along, he's at the stoplight in this orange thing, and everybody's looking, and then the light goes green. And he guns it, like, whoo, whoo! And he's only got about 70 yards to go, and the next light is red. He has to stop. And everybody collectively laughed at this guy in his face.
太棒了。太，太棒了。总之，联合酒馆，我要……好的。我刚才朝这个男人的脸上吐了口水。太棒了。太，太棒了。总之，联合酒馆，我要……我们马上回来。Viori听众们。Viori是高品质、时尚且可持续的运动服的终极目的地。一切都是为运动设计的，但看起来或感觉起来不像。太舒服了，你会想一直穿着它。老实说，它比你现在穿的任何东西都舒服
It was so good. It was so, so good. Anyway, Union Tavern, I'm gonna... OK. I just spat this guy in his face. It was so good. It was so, so good. Anyway, Union Tavern, I'm gonna... We'll be right back. Viori listener. Viori is the ultimate destination for high quality and stylish and sustainable active wear. Everything is designed to work out in, but it doesn't look or feel like it. So comfortable, you'll wanna wear it all the time. Honestly, it's comfier than whatever you're wearing
现在，我真的是Viori的穿着者。我大多穿运动短裤。非常舒服，我还有一件像套头衫，像夹克一样的东西，上面有很酷的小圆圈V标志，我觉得很运动。如果你在街上看到我，不同意的话，告诉我。否则，我会把你们的微笑当作确认。Viori是对你幸福的投资，听众们，他们正在为《SmartLess》的听众提供
right now. Now, I am truly a Viori wearer. Mostly I do the workout shorts. Very comfortable, and I also have a little bit of a like a jumper, like a jacket type of thing with the cool little circle V logo on it that I think is pretty sporty. If you see me on the street and you disagree, let me know. Otherwise, I'll take your smiles as a confirmation. Viori is an investment in your happiness listener and they're hooking up smart list listeners
在Viori.com斜杠smartlist首次购买8折优惠。那是V U O R I点com斜杠smartlist。你不仅会获得首次购买8折优惠，而且所有美国订单超过75美元还可享受免费送货和免费退货。前往Viori.com斜杠smartlist探索Viori服装的多功能性。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。你知道，今年过得太快了。
with 20% off your first purchase at Viori.com slash smart list. That's V U O R I dot com slash smart list. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any U S orders over $75 and free returns. Go to Viori.com slash smartlisten to discover the versatility of Viori clothing. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, this year's gone so quickly.
我的意思是，我很自豪到目前为止，我想我今年在做朋友、父亲或丈夫方面稍微好了一点。我每年都在努力做得更好。但你知道，如果你觉得有点力不从心，或者你认为你有点力不从心，我的意思是，BetterHelp会是个好主意。我的意思是，当生活过得这么快时，花点时间庆祝你的胜利并为今年剩下的时间做出调整是很重要的。治疗可以帮助你评估你的进展
I mean, I'm proud so far that I am, I think I'm slightly better at being a friend or father or husband this year. I've been trying every year to be better at that stuff. But you know, if you're coming up a little short or you think you're coming up a little short, I mean, better help would be a great idea. I mean, when life goes so fast, it is important to take a moment to celebrate your wins and make adjustments for the rest of the year. Therapy can help you take stock of your progress
并为接下来的六个月设定可实现的目标。如果你正在考虑开始治疗，试试BetterHelp。它完全在线，旨在方便、灵活，并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证治疗师匹配，并可随时更换治疗师，无需额外费用。
and set achievable goals for the next six months. If you're thinking about starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge.
花点时间，今天访问betterhelp.com斜杠smartlist，首次购买可享受9折优惠。那是betterhelp，H-E-L-P点com斜杠smartlist。感谢FanDuel支持本期《SmartLess》。夏天意味着棒球、NBA总决赛等等。你可以在FanDuel上押注这一切。现在，新客户只需5美元的获胜投注即可获得200美元的奖励投注。这200美元你可以用来投注从总决赛MVP到谁会打出
Take a moment, visit betterhelp.com slash smartlis today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash smartlis. Thank you to FanDuel for supporting this episode of SmartList. Summertime means baseball, the NBA Finals, and more. And you can bet it all on FanDuel. Right now, new customers get $200 in bonus bets with any winning $5 bet. That's $200 you can use to bet everything from the finals MVP to who's going to hit one
全垒打的一切。你知道当你抛硬币时，有时，你知道，你可以押注，是正面吗？是反面吗？那有时很有趣，伙计们。你知道，你不需要在这个世界上冒大风险就能真正获得乐趣。有时它可能只是一个简单的50-50命题，你知道，
out of the park. You know when you flip a coin sometimes, you know, you can bet, is it gonna be heads? Is it gonna be tails? That's sometimes fun, you guys. You know, you don't have to take big risks in this world to really have fun. Sometimes it can just be a simple 50-50 proposition, you know,
我敢打赌FanDuel能处理好。所以如果你想进行抛硬币比赛，试试FanDuel。嗯？访问FanDuel.com，斜杠，smartlist，并将一场大胜加入你的夏季愿望清单。FanDuel，美国第一体育博彩公司。21岁以上，适用排除条款。查看节目说明以获取完整免责声明。好了，回到节目。
and I'll bet you FanDuel can handle that. So if you want to have some coin flipping contests, try FanDuel. Huh? Visit FanDuel.com, slash, smart list and add a big win to your summer bucket list. FanDuel, America's number one sportsbook. 21 plus exclusions apply. See show notes for full disclaimer. All right, back to the show.
所以你刚得到它时没告诉家人。或者你只告诉了家人，没告诉别人？我只告诉了家人。哇，你只是，只是因为你不想什么？你为什么不像，为什么你不告诉全世界，就像，天哪，大家，我得到了这个该死的东西？哦不，我不被允许。哦东西？哦不，我不被允许。哦。
So you didn't tell your family when you first got it. Or you only told your family, nobody else? I only told my family. Wow, and you just, just because you didn't want what? Why weren't you like, why didn't you tell the world, like, oh my God, everybody, I got this fucking thing? Oh no, I wasn't allowed. Oh thing? Oh no, I wasn't allowed. Oh.
不，不，我不被允许。我非常认真地对待这一点。我知道约翰·博耶加说他上了出租车就立刻告诉了司机，但我太害怕说任何话了。不，我告诉了他，我告诉他时我爸爸睡着了，他说，耶稣基督。我走进门时告诉了我妈妈和姐姐。
No, no, I wasn't allowed. And I took that very seriously. I know John Boyega said he got in a cab and told the cabbie straight away, but I was like so scared to say anything. No, I told him, my dad was asleep when I told him and he went, Jesus Christ. And I told my mom and sister when I walked in.
是的。是的，然后我保密了。我的意思是，它彻底改变了你的整个人生。太令人兴奋了。我显然，如果你听的话，这些人对我太厌烦了，你可能也对谈论它太厌烦了，我很抱歉。但她是这个系列和你的一名超级粉丝。不，当然。
Yeah. Yeah, and then I kept it secret. I mean, it completely changed your whole life. It's so exciting. I'm obviously, if you listen, and these guys are so sick of me, and you're probably so sick of talking about it, I'm sorry. But she's a massive fan of the franchise and you. No, of course.
他想知道，他太尴尬而不敢问，哪颗行星是真的，你最喜欢的行星是谁，谁是你最喜欢的，或者我们的一名……我很期待你要拍的新的一部。你要拍新的一部还是三部，我们还不知道，但你在演，对吧？我目前在拍一部。你能告诉我们关于它的任何事吗？我可以告诉你，我很惊讶。我拍了一部电影。嗯，那信息不够，我想知道发生了什么。
He wants to know, he's too embarrassed to ask, which of the planets is real what's your favorite planet who is your favorite slash one of our I'm excited for the new one you're gonna do a new one or three or we don't know yet but you're playing right I'm doing one for now. Can you tell us anything about it? I can tell you, I was surprised. I made a movie. Well that's not enough information, I wanna know what happens.
嗯，我和我丈夫拍了一部电影叫《麦派》。我有一天拍摄休息，被邀请和凯西·肯尼迪吃早餐。我就想，真的。因为我们偶尔会一起吃饭。为了我姐姐特蕾西，凯西·肯尼迪制作了那些电影。是的，卢卡斯影业的负责人。
Well I made a movie with my husband called MacPy. And I had one day off shooting and I was invited to breakfast with Cathy Kennedy. And I was like, true. Because we occasionally take a meal together. And for my sister Tracy, Cathy Kennedy produces those films. Yes, ahead of Lucasfilm.
谢谢，肖恩。给你，那是我姐姐。我以为我们只是在吃早餐。我朋友说，哦，想象一下如果她们在拍另一部。我就想，我怀疑。早餐吃到一半，她说，我们在拍，你感觉如何？我就想，我怀疑。早餐吃到一半，她说，我们在拍，你感觉如何？
Thanks, Sean. There you go, that's my sister. And I thought we were just having breakfast. And my friend was like, oh, imagine if they're doing another rating. And I was like, I doubt it. And halfway through breakfast, she said, we are, how do you feel? And I was like, I doubt it. And halfway through breakfast, she said, we are, how do you feel?
我很惊讶。太酷了。但它，是的，是的，非常酷。不同的编剧，不同的导演。我想感觉会很不一样。谁在写，谁在导？是的，谁在写，谁在导？史蒂文·奈特在写。
And I was surprised. So cool. But it, yeah, yeah, it's very cool. Different writer, different director. It will be quite a different feeling, I imagine. Who's writing, who's directing? Yeah, who's writing, who's directing? Steven Knight is writing.
哦，不错。导演是沙敏·奥贝德-奇诺伊，她拍过一些令人难以置信的纪录片。这非常令人兴奋，我很快就会读剧本。太酷了。你得去什么秘密金库读剧本吗？不，我想我要去，不是秘密金库。也许她们会直接发给你。
Oh, nice. And directing is Sharmine Oboy-Chinoy who has made some unbelievable documentaries. And it's very exciting and I shall be reading a script soonish. That's so cool. Do you have to go to like a secret vault to read the script? No, I think I'm going to, not a secret vault. Maybe they'll just send it to you.
不，我想我得去某个地方。你读完后能发给我吗？是的，双击发过来就行。我会拍下每一页剧本。拜托。还有PDF，拜托。所以我猜你对《星球大战》上映后的所有关注、形象都有所准备，但它符合你的准备和预期吗？
No, I think I'll have to go somewhere. Will you send it to me after you read it? Yeah, just double click that over. I'll take a picture of every script page. Please. And a PDF, please. So I'd imagine that you are somewhat kind of self-prepared for all of the attention, the profile, after Star Wars came out, but did it match your preparation and expectations?
告诉我你是如何处理一夜之间无法走在街上的情况的。我不知道会发生什么，每个人都把它说得疯狂、疯狂、疯狂。显然，正如你们所知，当事情出来时，会有一阵活动，然后事情会平静下来。所以这很令人震惊，因为最初人们想聊天很奇怪，因为我没那么爱聊天。所以我当时会想，然后它又消失了。
Tell me how you dealt with being, you know, unable to walk down the street overnight. I didn't know what to expect, and everyone had made it out to be crazy, crazy, crazy. And obviously, as you all know, when things come out, there's a flurry of activity and then things sort of calm down again. So it was confronting because it was strange initially for people to want to chat because I'm not that chatty. So I'd be like, and then it sort of goes away again.
但人们非常友善，是的，它花了一些时间才到来。是的，但告诉我，我的意思是，我以前对其他人说过，像其他在这个系列里的人，但像JJ，或者不是JJ，但在这个系列里的人，像JJ，不是JJ，但其他演员在《星球大战》里，像亚当·德赖弗，无论谁，那是什么感觉，
But people are very nice and yeah, it sort of took its time to come. Yeah, but tell me like, I mean, I've said this before to other people like, like other people who've been in the franchise, but like JJ, or like not JJ, but people who've been in the franchise, like JJ, not JJ, but other actors have been in stars, is like Adam Driver, whoever, what is it like to be,
就像如果是我，我每天醒来都会想，我真不敢相信我在这部电影里。就像你，在这么年轻的时候，如何应对或压抑你的兴奋？就像你不能表现出来。他们拍你的时候得避开你的硬挺，我想。天哪。
like if it was me, I'd wake up every day and go, I can't fucking believe I'm in this movie. Like how do you, at such a young age, cope with or stuff your excitement? Like you can't show. You'd have a tough time, they'd have a tough time shooting around your boner, I guess. Oh my god.
不，句号。广角，广角。伙计们，我们要再拍紧一点。我们要在拍摄结束时补拍所有广角镜头。你们，该死的前六周只是覆盖镜头。不，但就像，在这么年轻的时候，太搞笑了。在这么年轻的时候，你只是，我知道你不能像，天哪。还有约翰·威廉姆斯，谈谈那个。
No full stop. Wide angle, wide angle. Guys, we're gonna go a little tighter again. We're gonna pick up all the wides at the end of the shoot. You guys, fucking first six weeks are just coverage. No, but like, at such a young age, that's so funny. At such a young age where you just, I know you can't like, holy shit. And then John Williams, talk about that.
就像写作，你有约翰·威廉姆斯为你写的专属主题曲，这是——我的意思是，我最喜欢的事情之一就是我和约翰·威廉姆斯是笔友。哦，哇。太酷了。是的，我真的，太疯狂了。第一次听到那个是什么感觉？太疯狂了。我的意思是，一开始大部分时间真的不知所措。我不记得所有事情的大部分内容了。
Like writing, you have your own theme written by John Williams, which is- I mean, my, one of my favorite things ever is me and John Williams are pen pals. Oh, wow. That's so cool. Yeah, I really, that's crazy. And what was it like to hear that for the first time? That was crazy. I mean, so much of it was honestly overwhelmed at the beginning. I can't remember a large chunk of everything.
就像写作一样，你有约翰·威廉姆斯为你创作的主题曲，我的意思是，我最喜欢的事情之一就是我和约翰·威廉姆斯是笔友。哇，太酷了。是的，这真的很疯狂。第一次听到那段音乐是什么感觉？那太疯狂了。说实话，一开始我感到非常震撼，以至于我不记得大部分细节了。
Ah, shit. But, I mean, even with filming, I can't remember, like, specifics. But also I had a group of people to sort of hold on to. And JJ, as you all know, is amazing. JJ's okay. JJ's okay. Well, we don't want him to get too far over his keys because we know he's listening.
啊，该死。但是，我的意思是，即使是在拍摄期间，我也记不清具体的细节了。不过我有一群人可以依靠。而且正如你们所知，JJ非常棒。JJ没问题。JJ没问题。好吧，我们不想让他太得意忘形，因为我们知道他在听。
He's just like, JJ, cool it, all right? Just cool it. And then I was so, like, I was in awe, like, preparing for this to go through YouTube and hear your unbelievable singing voice. Like I don't know that a lot of people know that, that you can sing so, like how did you, when did you first realize that
他就像是，JJ，冷静点，好吗？冷静点。然后我当时非常，就是，我感到敬畏，就像，准备好让这通过YouTube播放，听到你那令人难以置信的歌声。就像我不知道很多人知道这一点，你能唱得这么好，就像你是怎么，你什么时候第一次意识到
and why haven't we seen more of that? Well, I have had no shame in asking anyone to put me in a musical. Like literally no shame. I've done it on national TV, everything. It's gonna happen. It's not happened yet. It will. No, the Barbara Streisand thing,
为什么我们没有看到更多这样的表演？嗯，我一直毫不羞耻地请求任何人让我出演音乐剧。真的，一点也不羞耻。我在国家电视台上做过，什么都做过。这会发生的。虽然还没发生。但它会发生的。不，芭芭拉·史翠珊那件事，
which is another crazy thing, there's occasionally I'm like, oh my God, that was JJ. JJ introduced the two of us. And initially I met her because she was meant to be doing Gypsy. So that whole thing was so, yeah, yeah. Oh wow. Yeah, so there was a potential of testing to be in it.
那是另一件疯狂的事情，偶尔我会想，天哪，那是JJ。JJ把我们俩介绍认识的。起初我见到她是因为她本该出演《吉普赛人》。所以整件事就是这样，是的，是的。哦，哇。是的，所以有试镜出演它的可能性。
Oh wow. And I went to her house and it was, that was insane. I heard the house is crazy, like there's a mall underneath the house, like she has a shopping mall. Yeah, but I mean just sat with her, I was like, wow, you are Barbra Streisand. That is that sort of, you know, effervescence and power from someone is... Did you have to sing in front of her?
哦，哇。我去了她家，那真是太疯狂了。我听说那房子很疯狂，就像房子下面有个购物中心，她有一个购物中心。是的，但我的意思是，只是和她坐在一起，我就想，哇，你是芭芭拉·史翠珊。那种，你知道，来自某人的那种活力和力量是……你必须在她面前唱歌吗？
Well, we sang together. You recorded? Yeah, they recorded at the ballet from a chorus line. With Anne Hathaway. Huh. Yeah. It's a hard song to sing and you guys knocked it out of the park. It was so overwhelming and that weekend I also presented...
嗯，我们一起唱了。你们录音了吗？是的，他们在《歌舞线上》的芭蕾舞片段录了音。和安妮·海瑟薇一起。嗯。是的。那是一首很难唱的歌，你们表现得非常出色。那真是太令人震撼了，那个周末我还颁发了……
That was one of the craziest things. The film had come out, it was all nuts. And then I presented the Oscars with Dev Patel, which was wonderful. But the day before I had recorded with Barbra Streisand. And that weekend was one of those, what the fuck is going on? This is insane. That was one of those weekends. How'd old Tommy Bateman do through all that? Oh, we weren't together then.
那是当时最疯狂的事情之一。电影上映了，一切都乱套了。然后我和戴夫·帕特尔一起颁发了奥斯卡奖，那真是太棒了。但在那之前的一天，我和芭芭拉·史翠珊录了音。那个周末是那种，到底发生了什么？这太疯狂了。那是那样的周末之一。汤米·贝特曼在那期间表现如何？哦，我们那时还没在一起。
Yeah. No? Really? No, we met on Murder on the Orient Express. What do you think he was doing that weekend? Yeah, I'll tell you what he was doing. He was learning his lines for Based on a Orient Express. What do you think he was doing that weekend? Yeah, I'll tell you what he was doing. Learn his lines for Based on a True Story. You can see it on Peacock. You think before they wrote it, you think he was... Of course.
是吗？没有？真的吗？没有，我们在《东方快车谋杀案》中认识的。你觉得他那个周末在做什么？是的，我告诉你他在做什么。他在为《东方快车谋杀案》背台词。你觉得他那个周末在做什么？是的，我告诉你他在做什么。为《根据真实故事改编》背台词。你可以在Peacock上看到它。你觉得在他们写剧本之前，你觉得他……当然。
All Batemans work ahead. So, Shawnee, let's ask her about Murder on the Orient Express and if she can give us any tips about... Hang on. Cool it, Will. You're not on this trip. Shaw and I are gonna go on the Orient Express at some point, and we'd like a little bit of research from you on that.
所有的贝特曼都在努力工作。所以，肖尼，让我们问问她关于《东方快车谋杀案》的事，看她能不能给我们一些建议……等等。冷静点，威尔。你没参加这次旅行。肖和我打算在某个时候去坐东方快车，我们想从你那里做点研究。
Are you kidding? You guys won't even go to fucking La Cienega. You think you're gonna go to the Orient Express? It's like five blocks away. If anybody's going, it's me, go ahead. Yeah, tell us about the Orient Express. And Patrick Doyle is a wonderful friend of mine. He did the music for that movie. Thanks for starting the interview for that. about the Orient Express. And Patrick Doyle is a wonderful friend of mine.
你在开玩笑吗？你们甚至连拉谢内加都不去。你以为你们要去坐东方快车？那离这儿只有五个街区远。如果有人要去，那也是我，去吧。是的，告诉我们关于东方快车的事。帕特里克·多伊尔是我的一位好朋友。他为那部电影做了配乐。谢谢你开始那次采访。关于东方快车。
He did the music for that movie. Thanks for starting the interview for that. Thanks for the heads up, in case we bump into him. I wish I could tell you about the actual Orient Express. I got freebies, but I gave it to my parents. So they've been, and had the most amazing time. What did they say? I really want to do that. You're not coming.
他为那部电影做了配乐。谢谢你开始那次采访。谢谢你的提醒，以防我们碰到他。我真希望我能告诉你关于真正的东方快车的事。我得到了赠票，但我给了我父母。所以他们去了，玩得非常开心。他们说了什么？我真的很想去。你不能去。
I mean, it's unbelievable. You have to fully wear a suit to dinner, or, you know, evening attire. Sorry, Shonda has a question. No, not track suit. Keep going, Dizzy. LAUGHTER Wait, for what? You have to... You have to be... You have to be fancy. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
我的意思是，这太不可思议了。你必须穿全套西装去吃晚餐，或者，你知道，晚礼服。抱歉，肖恩有个问题。不，不是运动服。继续，迪兹。笑声 等等，为了什么？你必须……你必须……你必须穿得讲究。是的，是的，是的。
So, wait, listen to this. So, the last... So, the first time I was ever in London, like this is my last, Will's laughing. I'm just kidding. Will's having a tough time. Will's having a tough time. Jason keeps going, okay, okay. I mean, he's so kind of him to always prep us
所以，等等，听着。所以，最后……所以，我第一次去伦敦的时候，就像这是我最后一次，威尔在笑。我开玩笑的。威尔现在很难受。威尔现在很难受。杰森一直在说，好的，好的。我的意思是，他总是为我们准备好
for every sentence. Each one, here we go. But speaking of that, the first time I was ever in London. There's another one. What I just wanna say is, but wait, go ahead. But wait. I fucking love you. God damn it, I could do a whole day with you.
每一句话，真是太好了。每一句，我们开始吧。但说到这个，我第一次去伦敦的时候。又来了。我只想说，但等等，继续。但等等。我他妈的爱你。该死，我可以和你待上一整天。
This is all gonna keep you cut. Not two, just one. Keep going. God, are you kidding? In a fish market. So listen. So here's my. Here it is, here's another one, so listen.
这一切都会让你剪掉的。不是两个，只有一个。继续。天哪，你在开玩笑吗？在鱼市场。所以听着。所以这是我的。在这儿，又一个，所以听着。
Nevermind, it's not gonna, so listen. Never mind. It's not gonna be that great a story. Don't key yourself up, just say the thing. Okay, the first time I was in London, I had to go out to... God, you feel so naked without the... I'm sorry, we'll get back to your career, Daisy. We're new at this, Daisy, sorry. Daisy's so sorry.
算了，不会，所以听着。算了。那故事不会那么精彩。别太紧张，直接说吧。好吧，我第一次去伦敦的时候，我不得不去……天哪，没有那个你感觉好赤裸……抱歉，我们会回到你的职业生涯，黛西。我们是新手，黛西，抱歉。黛西很抱歉。
No, but take my dressing up. The first time I went to London, I went to this restaurant and they required a jacket for you to go sit down, like you're talking about the Art Express. And I didn't have one on, I had like a, I don't know what I had, like a dress. Should I take a guess what you had?
不，但拿我的装扮来说。我第一次去伦敦时，我去了这家餐厅，他们要求你穿夹克才能坐下，就像你说的东方快车那样。我没穿，我穿的是，我不知道我穿了什么，像是一件连衣裙。我要猜猜你穿了什么吗？
Hoodie, hoodie and a Chicago Cubs t-shirt. Yeah, with a cardigan underneath it. Exactly. I walk in and they're like, sorry sir, we can't serve you without a jacket. And so they said we have a closet full of jackets for you to choose from. And I was like, wait, what? And I'm like, the table we're sitting at
连帽衫，连帽衫和一件芝加哥小熊队的T恤。是的，里面还有一件开衫。没错。我走进去，他们说，抱歉先生，没有夹克我们不能为您服务。所以他们说我们有一个装满夹克的衣柜供您选择。我就想，等等，什么？我说，我们坐的桌子
is three feet away from us. Can I just walk to the table and sit down please? Like, no, you have to pick a jacket. There are these jackets in storage for people who show up with no jacket. So I put this oversized jacket from the 1980s or 90s. And I go to- Completely ruining your outfit.
离我们只有三英尺远。我能直接走到桌子旁坐下吗？就像，不行，你必须选一件夹克。储藏室里有这些夹克，是给那些没穿夹克就来的人准备的。所以我穿上了这件80年代或90年代的超大号夹克。然后我去——完全毁了你的装扮。
I don't, it was a long way to go for that story, sorry, Daisy. Wait, were you with Scotty? Yeah. Scotty had a jacket on? He did have a jacket on. You bet he did. Yeah.
我不，那个故事铺垫太长了，抱歉，黛西。等等，你和斯科蒂在一起吗？是的。斯科蒂穿了夹克吗？他确实穿了夹克。你打赌他穿了。是的。
He knows how to read. Anyway. Sorry, Daisy, Daisy, I'm so fucking sorry. This is just- Well, let's start over. I wanna know. Let's just start over. So, Murder on the Ornate Express, brilliant. I love that movie.
他知道怎么读。总之。抱歉，黛西，黛西，我他妈的太抱歉了。这只是——好吧，我们重新开始。我想知道。我们重新开始吧。所以，《东方快车谋杀案》，太棒了。我喜欢那部电影。
Sometimes I think about dying. I saw that fucking great American accent, great character. So into you. I can take my eyes off you every scene. Great story. Talk about the American accent, great character, so into you, I can take my eyes off you every scene. Talk about the American accent, Daisy. When was the first time that you can remember doing it? Maybe not even in a role. Do you remember the first time you tried it?
有时我会想到死亡。我看到了那他妈的伟大的美国口音，伟大的角色。太迷你了。每一场戏我都移不开眼。伟大的故事。谈谈美国口音，伟大的角色，太迷你了，每一场戏我都移不开眼。谈谈美国口音，黛西。你记得第一次做的时候是什么时候？也许甚至不是在角色里。你记得第一次尝试的时候吗？
No, I mean, as Brits, the American accent, one thinks of with LA is the like, oh my God thing. Like that is the thing. But I actually met my... That's really accurate. Yeah, that is accurate. I met my dialect coach through Tom Holland, who has been a guest on this show.
不，我的意思是，作为英国人，美国口音，人们想到洛杉矶就是那种“天哪”的感觉。就像那是那回事。但我实际上遇到了我的……那真的很准确。是的，那很准确。我通过汤姆·赫兰德认识了我的方言教练，他曾是这个节目的嘉宾。
Oh yes, we love Tom. Anytime a brick comes on, we always talk about American accents, because we're fascinated to hear ourselves. Well, his was so good, I was doing an English accent in that film, that in lockdown I was like, well I want to use my time wisely, so I started just doing American accent lessons.
哦，是的，我们爱汤姆。每当有英国人来，我们总是谈论美国口音，因为我们很着迷于听到我们自己的声音。嗯，他的太好了，我在那部电影里用的是英国口音，所以在封锁期间我就想，嗯，我想明智地利用我的时间，所以我开始只做美国口音练习。
And it served me well because I did three films with an American accent right after each other. Does it feel comfortable enough to you? You don't even have to think about it, you can just think about the acting? Well, the strangest thing was that I don't really have a process as such, and I want to be one of those people that does. But with an American accent, it sort of does give you that because I have to sit down and go through the whole thing
这对我很有帮助，因为我接连拍了三部用美国口音的电影。这对你来说感觉足够舒服吗？你甚至不需要去想它，你只需要考虑表演？嗯，最奇怪的是我并没有真正的过程，我想成为那种有过程的人。但有了美国口音，它确实给了你那种感觉，因为我必须坐下来把整件事过一遍
and have someone with me making sure I sound right. So it feels like it does feel like a process in a way. But I did two films in an English accent last year and thought, I cannot remember how to do this. And then I just did a film in an American accent and thought,, I cannot remember how to do this. And then I just did a film in an American accent and thought, I cannot fucking remember how to do this. So it's... So now you're lost, kind of in between, sort of.
并让某人陪着我确保我听起来是对的。所以它在某种程度上确实感觉像是一个过程。但我去年拍了两部用英国口音的电影，心想，我不记得怎么做这个了。然后我刚拍完一部用美国口音的电影，心想，我他妈的不记得怎么做这个了。所以……所以现在你迷失了，有点在两者之间，某种程度上。
Yeah, I'm like, who am I? You could go into mime work maybe instead. Is that a fix? When you work on an accent, so do you do it, were you doing it kind of... Well, obviously, like you said, you did during lockdown, and then you kind of work on it as you're leading up, and then work every day on that scene,
是的，我就像，我是谁？你也许可以去搞哑剧。那是个解决办法吗？当你练习口音时，你是怎么做的，你是……嗯，显然，就像你说的，你在封锁期间做的，然后你在准备过程中练习，然后每天在那场戏上工作，
sort of as you're getting ready, working with the dialect coach? No, because I... And I think that's a COVID thing. I've only done one film with the dialect coach on set, and she was doing everyone. Right. So usually I prep on the Sunday, and then I do the week as is, sort of alone, I suppose. And then ADR is obviously helpful.
就像你在准备时，和方言教练一起工作？不，因为我……而且我认为那是新冠带来的影响。我只拍过一部有方言教练在现场的电影，她当时在指导每个人。对。所以通常我在周日准备，然后我一周的时间，某种程度上是独自完成的，我想。然后ADR显然很有帮助。
Daisy, do you lean on an acting coach or any acting kind of thing, person, for each role? Are you like, you know what, I got this, I did the work, I studied, I went to school for it, I know what I'm doing. I do not lean on anyone, and I've not worked with an acting coach. That's not to say I think I... You don't need it.
黛西，你每个角色都会依赖表演教练或任何表演方面的人吗？你是那种，你知道吗，我搞定了，我做了功课，我学习了，我为此上了学，我知道我在做什么。我不依赖任何人，我也没和表演教练合作过。这并不是说我认为我……你不需要它。
I mean, I'm sure I do need it. No, because some actors do, some actors don't, you know. And even those that use them might not need them, they just, they like the interface. Yes, exactly. They like that sort of partnership, I think. Yeah, yeah. I like to be very,
我的意思是，我肯定我需要它。不，因为有些演员需要，有些演员不需要，你知道。即使是那些使用他们的人可能也不需要他们，他们只是，他们喜欢那种互动。是的，没错。我想他们喜欢那种伙伴关系。是的，是的。我喜欢非常，
I do all my thinking and all my work, and then I like to come,... I do all my thinking and all my work and then I like to come and I'm quite a... I don't... I take my work very seriously. I do not take myself very seriously. So I like to... I'm quite a messer-abouter on set, I suppose. But I'm never like interrupting anyone else and obviously there are times where we can't do that. But I like to really just have a great time on set. You haven't worked with Tom yet, have you?
我做所有的思考和所有的工作，然后我喜欢来……我做所有的思考和所有的工作，然后我喜欢来，我是一个相当……我不……我非常认真地对待我的工作。我并不太认真对待自己。所以我喜欢……我在片场相当爱捣乱，我想。但我从不打断别人，显然有些时候我们不能那样做。但我喜欢在片场真正玩得开心。你还没和汤姆合作过，对吧？
Well, just the film we met on. Ah, yeah, there's that. But we were not together then. So, no, and then he wrote the film we made last year. But he was filming based on a true story and we were filming here. And I think that would have been very difficult for him to have been on set, because I was acting and he was writing,
嗯，只是我们认识的那部电影。啊，是的，有那个。但我们那时还没在一起。所以，不，然后他写了我们去年拍的那部电影。但他当时在拍《根据真实故事改编》，我们在拍这里。我想如果他在片场对他来说会非常困难，因为我在演戏，他在写剧本，
and I was like, oh my God, I think that would have made me very self-conscious. So you guys are doing the movie together. How early on in the film did you start to see the first spark, you know? Walk us through it, because I know Will loves a good rom-com, he just likes to know the meat cutes and everything.
我就想，天哪，我想那会让我非常自我意识。所以你们一起拍电影。在电影拍摄的早期，你什么时候开始看到第一点火花，你知道？带我们走一遍，因为我知道威尔喜欢好的浪漫喜剧，他只是喜欢知道那些邂逅和所有的一切。
So just go slow for him. I love a meat cute. Yeah. Well, another of your guests, Penelope Cruz, sort of takes credit for us being together. Does she? Really? Yeah. It was sort of we were like best friends.
所以为他慢慢来。我喜欢邂逅。是的。嗯，你的另一位嘉宾，佩内洛普·克鲁兹，某种程度上把我们在一起归功于她。是吗？真的吗？是的。我们当时就像是最好的朋友。
That's how it starts. And then we were together. And then when we came back together for the premiere, Penelope, I'm not even gonna try and do her accent, but she said, your connection was so strong. Do it, try it right now. Your connection was so strong. That's great.
这就是开始。然后我们就在一起了。然后当我们回到首映式时，佩内洛普，我甚至不会尝试模仿她的口音，但她说，你们的联系太强烈了。模仿一下，现在就试一下。你们的联系太强烈了。那太棒了。
That's terrible, I'm so sorry. No, that's great. All Spanish people. That's really good. Yeah, so, but we were best friends immediately. Well, okay, so your best friend's on set, and there is, is he, do you get the sense that he is starting to feel like maybe things
那太糟糕了，我很抱歉。不，那很棒。所有的西班牙人。那真的很好。是的，所以，但我们立刻就成了最好的朋友。好吧，所以你最好的朋友在片场，而且有，他是吗，你有没有感觉到他开始觉得也许事情
are maybe gonna be better than friends? Oh my God, I've never talked about that. No, we're gonna walk right through this. Yeah, we have to. And then, were we, was the first, did like, did the first, was the first declaration of like, hey, I like, now you're talking to a guy, I've been married for 25 years.
也许会比朋友更好？天哪，我从来没谈过这个。不，我们要直接走过这个。是的，我们必须。然后，我们是，是第一次，是第一次宣告说，嘿，我喜欢，现在你在和一个家伙说话，我已经结婚25年了。
The last relationship, it was like school, right? Where you're passing notes, for Christ's sake. I don't know how this stuff happens. I like you. Yeah, you know, will you go with me? Or whatever the hell we used to say. Go with me, yeah. So how did it happen?
上一段感情，就像学校一样，对吧？你在传纸条，看在上帝的份上。我不知道这种事是怎么发生的。我喜欢你。是的，你知道，你会和我在一起吗？或者我们过去常说的任何鬼话。和我在一起，是的。所以它是怎么发生的？
Did you, did you pass him a note? Was it a little giggle after a take? What are we doing here? Accidentally brushing a hand. What are we doing? Yeah, let's get out of here. What's happening? Oh my God.
你，你给他传了纸条吗？是在一次拍摄后的小笑声吗？我们在这里做什么？不小心碰到了手。我们在做什么？是的，我们离开这里吧。发生了什么？天哪。
Do you want to share a ride to the hotel? Like tell me what happens, Daisy. So I want to know those answers. If you don't kiss me right now. Was it that clear? Daisy, come on. Daisy. Oh my God. I'll call Tom right now. I'll that clear? Daisy, come on. Daisy. Oh my God.
你想共乘去酒店吗？就像告诉我发生了什么，黛西。所以我想要那些答案。如果你现在不吻我。有那么清楚吗？黛西，拜托。黛西。天哪。我现在就给汤姆打电话。有那么清楚吗？黛西，拜托。黛西。天哪。
I'll call Tom right now. I'll get it from him. Or Daisy, how about this? Who asked who out first and what were the circumstances? Thank you, Sean. Oh my God. Oh my God, Tracy does not need to know. Tracy loves this.
我现在就给汤姆打电话。我会从他那里得到答案。或者黛西，这样怎么样？谁先约谁出去的，当时的情况是什么？谢谢你，肖恩。天哪。天哪，特雷西不需要知道。特雷西喜欢这个。
Are you kidding me? Wisconsin's on fire right now. This is the only thing we've never had to explain to her. This is how much she loves it. Oh my God. I've literally read. It's very cute. All right, so let's just, we're gonna fill in for you. Okay, so we're gonna assume that we're midway through the shoot. It's about a 30-day shoot. So we're in, you know, second week or whatever.
你在开玩笑吗？威斯康星州现在火了。这是我们唯一不需要向她解释的事情。这就是她有多喜欢它。天哪。我真的读过。这很可爱。好吧，所以让我们，我们要为你填补空白。好吧，所以我们假设我们是在拍摄中期。大约是30天的拍摄。所以我们在，你知道，第二周什么的。
And somebody's got a little issue with maybe a scene that's coming up. Maybe it's Daisy and she says, Tom, would you ever want to work on this? Maybe talk about it over coffee or dinner or something like that. Just with a straight face, like you could not care less, right? Because you're an actor, you're a professional liar. You're making him think like you couldn't care, like he's not your type. And then you guys get to the dinner, you're walking through the scene,
有人对即将到来的场景有点小问题。也许是黛西，她说，汤姆，你愿意在这上面工作吗？也许喝咖啡或吃晚饭时谈谈什么的。就面无表情，好像你一点也不在乎，对吧？因为你是个演员，你是个职业骗子。你让他觉得你好像不在乎，好像他不是你的菜。然后你们到了晚餐，你们在过场景，
you both brought your pages, whatever. And then you just start laughing about growing up as kids and what a great last name he's got. Have you ever met him? Oh my gosh, you know, did it kinda go like that? I bet it did. The thing is, it's not that crazy. Oh my God, we were just best friends
你们都带了剧本，什么的。然后你们就开始笑小时候长大的事，他有个多么棒的姓氏。你见过他吗？哦，天哪，你知道，是那样进行的吗？我打赌是。问题是，这并不那么疯狂。天哪，我们只是最好的朋友
and then we were together and now we're married. Who made the first move? Me. Oh. He did. He did, of course he did. We were best friends and then we moved together and now we're married. Who made the first move? He did. He did, of course he did. Good for him. We'll be right back. We get support from State Farm.
然后我们就在一起了，现在我们结婚了。谁先采取行动的？我。哦。他。他，当然是他。我们是最好的朋友，然后我们搬到一起，现在我们结婚了。谁先采取行动的？他。他，当然是他。他做得好。我们马上回来。我们得到State Farm的支持。
Nothing feels better than a personal win, right? From finishing a home DIY project, hitting a workout PR, or even just taking your car in for that oil change. If you define it as a win, it calls for a celebration. And who's cheering right beside you? State Farm. With the State Farm Personal Price Plan, you can create an affordable price just for you when you bundle home and auto. So celebrate by breaking out the confetti and those happy dance moves. Talk to a State Farm agent today to learn how you can bundle and save with a personal price plan.
没有什么比个人胜利感觉更好的了，对吧？从完成一个家庭DIY项目，打破健身记录，或者只是把你的车送去换机油。如果你把它定义为胜利，那就值得庆祝。谁在旁边为你欢呼？State Farm。有了State Farm个人价格计划，当你捆绑家庭和汽车保险时，你可以创建一个只适合你的负担得起的价格。所以通过拿出五彩纸屑和那些快乐的舞蹈动作来庆祝吧。今天就咨询State Farm代理人，了解如何通过个人价格计划捆绑和节省。
Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. Prices are based on rating plans that vary by state. Coverage options are selected by the customer. Availability, amount of discounts and savings, and eligibility vary by state. This episode of Smart List is brought to you in part by Skinny Pop Popcorn. Now, Skinny Pop Popcorn is something that is a part of my, you know, I mean, a lot of it goes in this face and I love it. And thank God it's somewhat, you know, it's right there in the title, it's Skinny. So, you know, if it weren't, there might be two of me because I do enjoy the stuff. Skinny Pop Original Popcorn is delicious and it's made with just three simple ingredients.
像个好邻居，State Farm就在那里。价格基于因州而异的费率计划。承保选项由客户选择。折扣和储蓄的可用性、金额以及资格因州而异。本集Smart List由Skinny Pop爆米花部分赞助。现在，Skinny Pop爆米花是我的一部分，你知道，我的意思是，很多都进了这张嘴，我喜欢它。谢天谢地，它有点，你知道，就在标题里，它是Skinny（瘦）。所以，你知道，如果不是这样，可能会有两个我，因为我确实喜欢这东西。Skinny Pop原味爆米花很美味，而且只用三种简单的原料制成。
Gotta love that. In addition to their original popcorn, Skinny Pop offers a variety of delicious flavors ranging from cheddar jalapeno to sweet and salty kettle. Shop Skinny Pop now. multi-kettle. Shop Skinny Pop now. offering stock trading, IRAs, and many more products to over 23 million funded customers. With Robinhood, it's simple to make investments towards your future goals, whatever those may be. Maybe you want to work towards investing for your family's future, maybe a vacation this summer, or visiting every baseball stadium in the country. We all have some bucket list items to cross off, and Robinhood has tools to help us pursue them. You know, it's pretty cool to have the power of investment and trading on your phone in the palm of your hand. It sounds really, really cool.
必须喜欢那个。除了他们的原味爆米花，Skinny Pop还提供各种美味的口味，从切达干酪墨西哥辣椒到甜咸水壶味。现在购买Skinny Pop。提供股票交易、IRA和更多产品给超过2300万资金充足的客户。有了Robinhood，为你的未来目标进行投资很简单，无论那些目标是什么。也许你想为家庭的未来投资，也许是今年夏天的假期，或者参观全国的每一个棒球场。我们都有一些愿望清单上的项目要划掉，而Robinhood有工具来帮助我们追求它们。你知道，在你的手机上，在你的手掌中拥有投资和交易的力量真的很酷。听起来真的很酷。
As far as long-term investing, a small amount invested now could make a big difference 30 years down the road. Take your financial future by the reins, download the app, or visit robinhood.com to learn more. Investing involves risk and loss of principal is possible. Returns are not guaranteed. Robinhood Financial LLC member SIPC is a registered broker dealer. Smartless is brought to you in part by Airbnb. Scotty and I had a couple friends in recently,
至于长期投资，现在投入的一小笔钱在30年后可能会产生巨大的差异。掌控你的财务未来，下载应用程序，或访问robinhood.com了解更多。投资涉及风险，本金损失是可能的。回报不保证。Robinhood Financial LLC是SIPC成员，是一家注册经纪交易商。Smartless由Airbnb部分赞助。斯科蒂和我最近有几个朋友，
actually more than two, and they rented an Airbnb because we didn't have the space for them. And we went over there and it was like beautiful. It was gorgeous. And I was like, wow, I can't believe people rent their places out like this. And they do because it's such a good idea. I don't know, maybe you've stayed in an Airbnb before
实际上不止两个，他们租了一个Airbnb，因为我们没有空间给他们。我们过去看了，它看起来很漂亮。它太华丽了。我就想，哇，我不敢相信人们会这样出租他们的地方。他们确实这样做了，因为这是一个好主意。我不知道，也许你以前住过Airbnb
and thought to yourself, this actually seems pretty doable. Maybe my place could be an Airbnb. It could be as simple as starting with a spare room or your whole place when you're away. You could be sitting on an Airbnb and not even know it. Maybe you're planning a getaway this year. While you're away, you could Airbnb your home and make some extra money toward the trip.
并对自己说，这实际上看起来很可行。也许我的地方可以成为一个Airbnb。这可以很简单，从一个空余房间开始，或者当你不在家时出租整个地方。你可能坐拥一个Airbnb却不知道。也许你今年正在计划度假。当你不在家时，你可以把你的家Airbnb出去，赚一些额外的钱来支付旅行费用。
Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at airbnb.ca slash host. And now back to the show. So I want to talk a little bit about Young Woman in the Sea, which I tried to watch and I couldn't. But tell me about the prep for that. and then I want to talk about projects like, how do you choose what's important to you? The prep for Young Woman in the Sea was,
你的家可能比你想象的更值钱。在airbnb.ca slash host上找出价值多少。现在回到节目。所以我想谈谈《年轻女子与海》，我试着看但我没看成。但告诉我关于那的准备工作。然后我想谈谈项目，比如，你是如何选择对你来说重要的东西的？《年轻女子与海》的准备工作是，
I could not swim a full length when I first started swim training. And then three months later, I was plonked in the Black Sea for nine days while we filmed the swim. In fact, the two attempts that Trudy made. You shot that in the Black Sea for nine days while we filmed the swim. In fact, the two attempts that Trudy made. You shot that in the Black Sea? Yeah.
我刚开始游泳训练时连一整圈都游不下来。三个月后，我被扔进黑海九天，我们拍摄了游泳过程。事实上，特鲁迪做的两次尝试。你在黑海拍了九天，我们拍摄了游泳过程。事实上，特鲁迪做的两次尝试。你在黑海拍的？是的。
Off the coast of? Bulgaria. Bulgaria, okay. Does that track well? That tracks, yeah. No, Sofia is the capital. Keep going. Yeah. Yeah.
在……海岸外？保加利亚。保加利亚，好的。那说得通吗？那说得通，是的。不，索非亚是首都。继续。是的。是的。
So two and a half months swimming prep and then a shoot, which obviously was not all swimming, but a lot of swimming, and then ending with those nine days. So I was pretty tired after that. Yeah, you think you're in shape until you start swimming, right? I mean, swimming is just the hardest thing to do. I think you're endurance.
所以两个半月的游泳准备，然后是拍摄，显然不是全部都在游泳，但有很多游泳，最后是那九天。所以我之后很累。是的，你以为你身材很好，直到你开始游泳，对吧？我的意思是，游泳是最难做的事情。我想你的耐力。
Yeah, I can't do it. I can't do it. I run out of breath so quickly, even from one lap in the pool. Is that right, Charm? Oh yeah, I literally came up halfway and was the first time and said I don't think I can do this. But my swimming coach is also an Olympian.
是的，我做不到。我做不到。我很快就喘不过气来，即使在游泳池里游一圈也是。是这样吗，肖恩？哦，是的，我第一次游到一半就上来了，说我不认为我能做到。但我的游泳教练也是奥运选手。
She won silver at Rio. So the whole time I was like... And now because we're friends, I introduce her as an Olympian and every time she's like, can you just not? But she's so amazing. Why did she not want to be known as an Olympian? Because she's so sweet and so modest. What's her name?
她在里约赢得了银牌。所以整个过程中我都在想……现在因为我们是朋友，我介绍她是奥运选手，每次她都说，你能别这样吗？但她太棒了。为什么她不想被称为奥运选手？因为她太甜美、太谦虚了。她叫什么名字？
Siobhan Marie O'Connor. Siobhan Marie O'Connor. If you see her on the street and approach her and congratulate her on the Olympics. Yeah. That's so cool. So when you're working out with somebody like that, who is quite legit, like an Olympic swimmer, who's won medals, do you get motivated
西沃恩·玛丽·奥康纳。西沃恩·玛丽·奥康纳。如果你在街上看到她，走过去祝贺她参加奥运会。是的。那太酷了。所以当你和那样的人一起锻炼时，谁相当合法，像奥运游泳选手，赢过奖牌，你会感到有动力吗
by how good she is? You're like, I'm exhausted, but I don't want to let her down, so I'm just gonna keep going. Yeah, yeah. Also, she retired early because she got ill, and she was still swimming with her illness, so that's like a double whammy of unbelievable. Wow.
因为她有多好？你就像，我精疲力竭，但我不想让她失望，所以我只是要继续前进。是的，是的。而且，她因为生病提前退役了，她还在带着病游泳，所以那就像是令人难以置信的双重打击。哇。
Yes, and also I knew, you know, you get to sit and you're like, well, this is what I signed up for. So I also didn't want to let anyone else down and I wanted to be able to do the thing even though... Sean got ill once swimming, but it's because he ate a pound of gummies too soon before he went in the pool. Full pound.
是的，而且我也知道，你知道，你坐下来想，嗯，这就是我签名的原因。所以我也不想让其他人失望，我想能够做这件事，尽管……肖恩有一次游泳生病了，但那是因为他在进游泳池前太早吃了一磅软糖。整整一磅。
Yeah, couldn't sleep that night either. Sour Patch! Hey, Daisy, what's it like just bobbing in the open ocean, having to do a bunch of work for days and days and days? Didn't you think the odds of you having a little bit of a nudge from a large fish? Yeah. Pretty big, right? Well, I knew there were no sharks, but there are jellyfish.
是的，那天晚上也睡不着。酸味软糖！嘿，黛西，在开阔的海洋里漂浮，不得不连续几天做大量的工作是什么感觉？你没想过你被大鱼撞一下的几率吗？是的。很大，对吧？嗯，我知道没有鲨鱼，但有水母。
How did you know that? Who told you that? What are they, Colin Sick? The Black Sea specialists told me that there were no sharks, but there were actual unexploded mines. Geez. Wait, wait, is that true? There's no sharks in the Black Sea?
你怎么知道的？谁告诉你的？他们是什么，科林·西克？黑海专家告诉我没有鲨鱼，但有实际未爆炸的地雷。天哪。等等，等等，那是真的吗？黑海里没有鲨鱼？
No. But there are jellyfish and there are mines. And we were told that where we were, the mines had been exploded. And that was not comforting. That was... Wow, I've been exploding mines for a long time. Yeah. Oh, mines. M-I-E. Got it, got it, got it.
没有。但有水母，还有地雷。我们被告知我们所在的地方，地雷已经被引爆了。那并不令人安慰。那……哇，我一直在引爆地雷很长时间了。是的。哦，地雷。M-I-E。明白了，明白了，明白了。
And each time it was really cold and very overwhelming, because you're fighting against the current, and then I had to keep pace with the follow boat that's in the film, and then I had to keep pace with the camera boat that's on the other side. And also I was afraid of open water. It's Jerry Bruckheimer that produced the film. And I did say to the producers and the writer and director, I am afraid of open water and I think they thought I was joking.
而且每次都很冷，非常令人不知所措，因为你在对抗水流，然后我必须跟上电影里的跟随船，然后我必须跟上另一边的摄像船。而且我还害怕开阔水域。是杰瑞·布鲁克海默制作了这部电影。我确实对制片人、编剧和导演说，我害怕开阔水域，我想他们以为我在开玩笑。
But like I wasn't joking. So each time I got in, I had to... Yeah, me too. How did you not just pass on the movie, being that that's one of your fears? Because I really wanted to do the movie. I mean, I did a film just before Christmas where I am a window cleaner. We were calling it Dye Shard. Were you scared of windows?
但就像我没开玩笑。所以每次我进去，我都必须……是的，我也是。你为什么没有放弃这部电影，既然那是你的恐惧之一？因为我真的很想拍这部电影。我的意思是，圣诞节前我拍了一部电影，我在里面是个擦窗工。我们叫它《玻璃硬汉》。你怕窗户吗？
I'm terrified of cleaning windows. Height, I'll bet. I'm terrified of heights. There it is. Wait, Daisy, what were you calling it? You were calling it what? Dye Shard. Dye Shard, that's so good.
我非常害怕擦窗户。高度，我敢打赌。我恐高。就是这样。等等，黛西，你叫它什么？你叫它什么？《玻璃硬汉》。《玻璃硬汉》，那太好了。
You know, a thing goes on and I, well I have to fight my way into the building and save the day, Allah, Allah die hard. But yeah, I'm afraid of heights. And at that point I thought, why do I keep doing this? But the roles are so good, you know? And it's a great time to overcome something. I love that, yeah, yeah. It's great.
你知道，事情发生了，我，嗯，我必须打进大楼并拯救世界，阿拉，阿拉《虎胆龙威》。但是的，我恐高。在那一刻我想，我为什么一直这样做？但角色太好了，你知道吗？这是一个克服某些事情的好时机。我喜欢那个，是的，是的。这很棒。
I mean, were there moments where you're like, and I'm not kidding, were you like, how do I get out of this? Or were you like, never? Yeah, there were, and then, I mean do I get out of this? Or were you never? Yeah, there were. And then, I mean, the scariest moment of Young Woman in the Sea was when we were flying home after rap and the director, Joakim, said,
我的意思是，有没有那么一刻你觉得，我不是在开玩笑，你觉得，我怎么摆脱这个？或者你觉得，从来没有？是的，有，然后，我的意思是，我怎么摆脱这个？或者你从来没有？是的，有。然后，我的意思是，《年轻女子与海》最可怕的时刻是我们在杀青后飞回家，导演乔阿基姆说，
so basically, after the shot was over, I would have to get on like a life raft and then the safety boat would grab the life raft and pull me to safety, essentially. And Joakim said, oh, there was a time where your leg was dragging right under the propeller and I thought your leg was gonna be cut off. Oh, God.
所以基本上，镜头结束后，我必须坐上救生筏，然后安全船会抓住救生筏并把我拉到安全地带，本质上。乔阿基姆说，哦，有一次你的腿就在螺旋桨下面拖着，我以为你的腿会被切断。哦，上帝。
Well, I guess it's better to know after the fact. Yeah, but no, it was all pretty scary. So you're looking for a nice sitcom right about now, yeah? Yeah, I'm looking for something more. Sitting down, having a nice time. about now, yeah? A little multi-cam studio audience. Yeah, sitting down, having a nice time. And just the trajectory of your career is so impressive from that pub to getting to Star Wars and now just working constantly with such impressive work
嗯，我想事后知道总比不知道好。是的，但没有，这一切都相当可怕。所以你现在正在寻找一部好的情景喜剧，对吧？是的，我在寻找更多的东西。坐下来，玩得开心。现在，对吧？一点多机位演播室观众。是的，坐下来，玩得开心。而且你的职业生涯轨迹太令人印象深刻了，从那个酒吧到《星球大战》，现在只是不断地与如此令人印象深刻的作品合作
and being around so many people that know what they're doing and are at the top of their game. Is there, of those people you've worked with so far, is there some kind of advice somebody gave you at one point where just like, wow, and it really stuck with you? Or something that kind of moved you in a way that you're like, I gotta hang on to that? I had a dinner with someone who's quite big
并且身边有这么多知道自己在做什么并且处于游戏顶端的人。在那些你目前合作过的人中，有没有某人给你的某种建议，让你觉得，哇，它真的让你印象深刻？或者某种以某种方式触动你的东西，让你觉得，我必须抓住它？我和一个相当大的人吃过晚饭
in the film world, and he goes, your career is so interesting. And I was like, ah. And at the time I thought, is that a good thing? But actually I am not someone who has planned things out. I just know what I like and I go with what's available and that I like. So I am sort of, I'm trying not to look sideways
在电影界，他说，你的职业生涯太有趣了。我就想，啊。当时我想，那是件好事吗？但实际上我不是一个把事情计划好的人。我只是知道我喜欢什么，我随遇而安，我喜欢什么就做什么。所以我有点，我尽量不往旁边看
and doing my own thing. Yeah, so quote, your career is interesting wasn't great advice. It was just a comment. Well, it was a comment, but it made me think, oh, I mean, should I be more strategic? And actually I thought, no, because the stuff I've got to do has been very wide ranging. Like sometimes I thought, no, because the stuff I've got to do has been very wide ranging.
做我自己的事。是的，所以引用，“你的职业生涯很有趣”不是什么好的建议。那只是一个评论。嗯，那是一个评论，但它让我思考，哦，我的意思是，我应该更具战略性吗？实际上我想，不，因为我必须做的事情范围非常广。就像有时我想，不，因为我必须做的事情范围非常广。
Like sometimes I think about dying, we made in 23 days with a tiny budget and it was as enriching as Star Wars, which is, you know, many, many, many times that, both budget and filming wise. That's interesting. Whatever you're doing, it's right. I mean, you're doing things that are challenging you
就像有时我会想到死亡，我们用23天拍完，预算很小，它和《星球大战》一样丰富，你知道，那是很多很多倍，无论是预算还是拍摄方面。那很有趣。无论你在做什么，都是对的。我的意思是，你在做挑战你的事情
and we can't do anything about who's gonna see something, who it's for, where it's gonna be, when it's gonna be released, all that stuff. We just gotta do our job, right? And do the things that feed us. So it sounds like you're making the right decision. Ben Mendelsohn said something because I used to feel more, I suppose,
我们无法控制谁会看到什么，它是给谁的，它会在哪里，什么时候发布，所有这些东西。我们只需要做好我们的工作，对吧？做那些滋养我们的事情。所以听起来你做出了正确的决定。本·门德尔森说过一些话，因为我过去感觉更多，我想，
like it was my fault how something was going to perform or not. And Ben was like, we just do the work we do and then, that's it. You know, what more can you do? As Jason Bateman said to me decades ago, none of this is up to you. And that stuck with me forever. You only have one part in it all. Yeah. Daisy Ridley, what is Daisy Ridley doing in between gigs?
好像某件事表现如何是我的错。本说，我们只是做我们做的工作，然后，就这样。你知道，你还能做什么？正如杰森·贝特曼几十年前对我说的，这一切都不由你决定。那永远留在了我心里。你在这一切中只有一个角色。是的。黛西·雷德利，黛西·雷德利在工作间隙在做什么？
Because she works so much. What do you do with your time off? This week I'm going to see, though it's supposed to be a surprise, Sarah Snook in Dorian Gray on Thursday. We won't tell her. Okay, wow. I read, watch movies. We went to go see Monkey Man on...
因为她工作太多了。你休息时间做什么？这周我要去看，虽然这应该是个惊喜，周四去看莎拉·斯努克演的《道林·格雷》。我们不会告诉她。好的，哇。我阅读，看电影。我们去看了《猴人》在……
Oh, I hear that's great. I want to see that. What is that? I haven't heard of that. It's great. Dev Patel, director, actor... Director, star. That's his first film he directed, right? It's... The action is sick.
哦，我听说那很棒。我想看那个。那是什么？我没听说过。它很棒。戴夫·帕特尔，导演，演员……导演，主演。那是他执导的第一部电影，对吧？它是……动作很酷。
It's really an impressive film. I have seen that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Lots of hanging out, see my family impressive film. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Lots of hanging out, see my family a lot. See my nephews a lot. Kids have bigger family in the future for you and maybe some kids? Geez, what a really good person.
这真是一部令人印象深刻的电影。我见过那个。是的，是的，是的。很多闲逛，见我的家人令人印象深刻的电影。是的，是的，是的。很多闲逛，见我的家人很多。见我的侄子很多。未来有更大的家庭和一些孩子吗？天哪，真是个好人。
Maybe. I know, I'm like, wow, what am I thinking about that? I don't know, I'll just ask him. I'm obsessed with my nephews. I love them so much. How old are they? They are, the little ones are two and a half and six months.
也许。我知道，我就想，哇，我在想那个干什么？我不知道，我只是问他。我痴迷于我的侄子。我太爱他们了。他们多大了？他们是，小的两岁半和六个月。
And they're just delightful little squishy boys. I love that. Well, Daisy, it's now much later in the UK. You've been such a joy to be here today. Thank you for doing this. I know, you've been so generous. Huge fan, like crazy fan. Sean won Star Wars, Sean won Star Wars question.
他们只是令人愉快的软绵绵的小男孩。我喜欢那个。好吧，黛西，英国现在晚多了。今天能在这里真是太高兴了。谢谢你做这件事。我知道，你太慷慨了。超级粉丝，像疯狂的粉丝。肖恩赢了星球大战，肖恩赢了星球大战问题。
We'll let you have one. You know what, go wake up Scotty and tell him to get over here and ask a question. Don't worry, he beamed Scotty up a while ago. Hey-o. Hey-o. No, I mean I had tons of Star Wars questions. Well then let's see one.
我们会让你有一个。你知道吗，去叫醒斯科蒂，告诉他过来问个问题。别担心，他不久前就把斯科蒂传送上来了。嘿-哦。嘿-哦。不，我的意思是，我有成吨的星球大战问题。那让我们看一个。
Which is the best one. Well, okay, let me just look. Oh my God, you really have them all written down. I do, I wrote them down. When you were on Endalore. Okay, so, no, I have a question about the test process, but you kind of talked about that. I have a question about, oh, here's one.
哪个是最好的。好吧，好吧，让我看看。天哪，你真的把它们都写下来了。我写了，我写下来了。当你在恩多时。好吧，所以，不，我有一个关于测试过程的问题，但你谈到了那个。我有一个关于，哦，这里有一个。
It has a massive fan base, Star Wars, obviously I'm one of them, but how does it feel to be part of such a beloved franchise and like do you feel a responsibility towards, you know, the fans? Like did you feel the weight of that? And were you a fan before? I would not have called myself a fan from before, no. I had seen some of them.
它有一个庞大的粉丝群，星球大战，显然我是其中之一，但成为这样一个深受喜爱的特许经营的一部分是什么感觉，你是否对粉丝感到一种责任？就像你感受到了那种重量吗？你之前是粉丝吗？我不会称自己为之前的粉丝，不。我看过一些。
And then when I was auditioning I was like, oh, this is everywhere. And it was one of those things of suddenly there was... So you didn't know that before? You were like, oh, this is everywhere. You're making Sean angry. No, no, it was... I mean I was aware of it. But you know when you're auditioning for something it is very present in your world. That it's there and you want the thing.
然后当我试镜时，我就想，哦，这到处都是。这是那种突然间有……所以你之前不知道？你就像，哦，这到处都是。你在让肖恩生气。不，不，它是……我的意思是，我意识到它。但你知道当你为某事试镜时，它在你的世界里非常存在。它就在那里，你想要那个东西。
And I remember seeing a Princess Leia t-shirt. I thought, oh, okay. And then every book I read, there was a reference. In every film I watched, there was a reference. So it was one of those things. And then the love grew. But also I think that was good because I was... Cool it. Yeah, easy. I was just...
我记得看到一件莱娅公主的T恤。我想，哦，好的。然后我读的每一本书，都有一个参考。我看的每一部电影，都有一个参考。所以它是那种事情之一。然后爱就增长了。但我也认为那很好，因为我当时……冷静点。是的，容易。我只是……
Like I was so wondrously happy to be there. But because I didn't quite understand how far-reaching it was. Did you know that it's... He's not Baby Yoda. He's actually a different name, but everybody calls him Baby Yoda. By the way, can you see it? Have you got one up there? Can you see him up there? Right in the back, up there? Oh, sweet.
就像我非常高兴能来到这里。但因为我不太明白它有多深远。你知道它是……他不是尤达宝宝。他实际上有另一个名字，但每个人都叫他尤达宝宝。顺便问一下，你能看到吗？你上面有一个吗？你能看到他吗？就在后面，上面？哦，甜美。
What's he called, Sean? His... Oh, God. Birth name. Grogu. Gro Oh, sweet. What's he called, John? His, oh God. Birth name. Grogu. Grogu, yeah. It's actually Grogu. I was put on the spot, I was so nervous. I know you are, Angel.
他叫什么名字，肖恩？他的……天哪。出生名。格罗古。格罗……噢，太好了。他叫什么名字，约翰？他的，天哪。出生名。格罗古。格罗古，对。其实是格罗古。我当时被问住了，我太紧张了。我知道你很紧张，安吉尔。
Careful of your heart, okay? Can I ask you one more question about it? Where are the paddles? What? Can I ask you one more question about it? Please. And then, so. We're so sorry, Daisy.
小心你的心脏，好吗？我能再问你一个关于它的问题吗？除颤器在哪？什么？我能再问你一个关于它的问题吗？拜托。然后，所以。我们很抱歉，黛西。
When it, after it came out, were you like, the rush of it, like what was the downside after it? Like, because the announcement of it, the announcement of the cast, and then the shooting of it, and then it came out, and all of it was so massive, and then you rapped, and then what is that moment like?
当它，在它上映之后，你有没有那种感觉，就是那种热潮，之后有什么负面影响吗？比如，因为它的官宣，演员阵容的官宣，然后拍摄，然后它上映了，这一切都太宏大了，然后你杀青了，那一刻是什么感觉？
I mean, the rap at the very end was, someone has it recorded somewhere. I was crying so much it was hilarious. I couldn't speak. I was going, I'm having such a good time. Like I was one of those wailing people that was looking around at these wondrous people that had been there for 18 months of my life.
我是说，最后杀青的时候，有人在某处录下来了。我哭得太厉害了，太搞笑了。我话都说不出来。我当时在想，我玩得太开心了。我就像那些嚎啕大哭的人之一，环顾四周，看着这些在我生命中陪伴了18个月的奇妙的人们。
Oh my God. That was very emotional. But was there a sense of like, what the hell am I gonna do next? Like, what am I gonna do now? Oh yeah. Yeah, yeah. Because that January after we were all, oh yeah.
天哪。那真的很感人。但有没有一种感觉，比如，接下来我该怎么办？比如，我现在该做什么？噢，是的。是的，是的。因为那个一月之后我们都，噢，是的。
The January after they were all done, it just felt so quiet. Like, you know, you just spend all your time with, and particularly on press tours, when you're with people all hours of the day, that was very strange. And then we went into lockdown. So that was all like a very strange experience
他们都结束后的一月，感觉太安静了。你知道，你把所有时间都花在，特别是在新闻巡回宣传时，你整天都和人们在一起，那感觉非常奇怪。然后我们就进入了封锁期。所以那一切就像是一次非常奇怪的经历，
of having to sit quietly. Must have just been like, wow, like the sets and the costumes, like it's just amazing to me. And then last one, can you give me anything at all that Cathy Kennedy told you about the movie? I know you haven't read the script yet, but any kind of nugget, anything, anything
不得不安静地坐着。一定就像是，哇，那些布景和服装，对我来说简直太神奇了。最后一个问题，你能告诉我凯西·肯尼迪关于这部电影告诉你的任何事情吗？我知道你还没读剧本，但任何一点消息，任何东西，任何
about Ray in the next movie? I'll be in it. No. How about this? Would you be possibly open to, subject to the rules of the set and everything, of Sean, and maybe me and Will... Stormtrooper.
关于蕾伊在下一部电影里的事？我会参演。不。这个怎么样？你是否可能愿意，在遵守片场规则和一切的前提下，肖恩，也许还有我和威尔……冲锋队员。
No, no, showing up on set doing a bit of a remote episode of a very special Star Wars smart list on set. We interview you, maybe JJ can pop by, I mean, whoever else. Yeah? I mean, I feel really Are you sure? Yeah? I mean, I feel really bad because the only person I ever had... Oh, morning Mr. McPie. I had visit in a friend through work, where was Josh Gad. And he came the day...
不，不，出现在片场，做一个非常特别的《星球大战》SmartLess节目的远程剧集。我们采访你，也许JJ可以过来，我是说，还有其他人。好吗？我是说，我真的……你确定吗？好吗？我是说，我感到非常糟糕，因为我唯一曾经……噢，早上好，麦克派先生。我曾通过工作拜访过一位朋友，那是乔什·盖德。他来的那天……
The scene was that I was Palpatine's granddaughter. And he literally said, you ruined my fucking life. It was like, why did you bring me today? And I just didn't think. No, I get it. Because wait, your pulpit is for ranzar. And I felt so riddled with guilt. Riddled with guilt?
那场戏是我扮演帕尔帕廷的孙女。他真的说，你毁了我他妈的生活。就像是，你今天为什么要带我来？我当时没多想。不，我明白。因为等等，你的帕尔帕廷是……我感到充满了内疚。充满了内疚？
Yeah. I was riddled with guilt. So now I'm so scared. I don't want to ruin anything for anyone. Wait, no, but you can't say anything about that. Don't get her fired. Shia, no, I just, but there's gotta be something that you can give that doesn't give anything away.
是的。我充满了内疚。所以我现在太害怕了。我不想毁了任何人的任何事。等等，不，但你不能说关于那个的任何事。别让她被解雇了。肖恩，不，我只是，但一定有什么东西是你可以在不泄露任何信息的情况下说的。
Look, I won't press. Some time has passed. Some time in the past. Wait, something in the past? No, no, some time has passed. Oh, some time has passed. Yes, and you said some time in the past. I think it is in the past.
听着，我不会逼问。过去了一些时间。过去的一些时间。等等，过去的一些事？不，不，过去了一些时间。噢，过去了一些时间。是的，而你说的是过去的一些时间。我想是在过去。
Oh, really? And I think we might film next year. Might film next year. Okay, we've got it. That's enough, that's enough. That's at least something. But anyway, Daisy. Start laying out your outfit now, Sean.
噢，真的吗？我想我们明年可能会拍摄。明年可能会拍摄。好了，我们知道了。够了，够了。这至少算点什么。但不管怎样，黛西。现在开始准备你的行头吧，肖恩。
I feel like she might. I think I have part of it on. I have underoos on. Star Wars underoos. Daisy, you're such a pleasure. Thank you for being here. Youos on. I thought it was underoos. Daisy, you're such a pleasure. Thank you for being here. You really are.
我觉得她可能会。我想我身上穿了一部分。我穿着内裤。星球大战内裤。黛西，你真是太讨人喜欢了。谢谢你来到这里。你真是。
Thank you so much for doing this. Such a joy. Please say hi to Tom. Thank you. I will do. Absolutely love you and love everything about you. Thanks, guys. Thanks, Daisy.
非常感谢你做这些。太开心了。请代我向汤姆问好。谢谢。我会的。绝对爱你，爱你的一切。谢谢，伙计们。谢谢，黛西。
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. She's the sweetest. I love how cute she was when we asked her about how they met and how she turned her husband. Certain things are private, okay?
再见。再见。再见。再见。她是最贴心的。我喜欢当我们问她他们是怎么认识的以及她是如何改变她丈夫时她那可爱的样子。有些事情是私人的，好吗？
And then you get to just fill in the blanks, like I did, and we wrote our little airport romance novel. We did pry, we did pry for sure. But yeah, it must be, I love watching what she's doing after, you know, ASW, after Star Wars, to create a career for herself and all these other. It doesn't need an acronym at all. It's not a thing.
然后你就可以填补空白了，就像我做的那样，我们写了我们的小机场浪漫小说。我们确实打听了，我们确实打听了。但是的，这一定，我喜欢看她之后在做什么，你知道，ASW，在《星球大战》之后，为自己创造事业以及所有这些其他的。它根本不需要缩写。那不是个东西。
Yeah. Okay. But all of these movies that she's done is really kind of stretching her skills, and it's awesome to see because she knocks it out of the park every time. She's balancing like that big, huge, global commercial thing with like these great small independent films as well and the stuff in the middle.
是的。好的。但她拍的所有这些电影真的在某种程度上扩展了她的技能，看到这一点很棒，因为她每次都表现得非常出色。她平衡了那种大型的、巨大的、全球商业化的东西和这些伟大的小型独立电影，以及中间的东西。
Like prestige films in between. Like, yeah, yeah, yeah. It's the way to do it. Sweet girl. And maybe the best name in Hollywood. Daisy Ridley. That's a hard one to beat. Daisy Ridley.
中间的那些名望电影。比如，是的，是的，是的。这就是该做的方式。甜美的女孩。也许是好莱坞最好的名字。黛西·雷德利。这很难被超越。黛西·雷德利。
It's so tremendous. What a name. Isn't it? Oh, by the way, you guys, Young Woman in the Sea is in theaters right now. I'm excited for that. I do want to see that. I mean, I'm scared as well of that.
太棒了。多好的名字。不是吗？噢，顺便说一下，伙计们，《年轻女子与海》现在正在影院上映。我很期待那个。我确实想看那个。我是说，我也对那个感到害怕。
Open Water, even watching somebody like those films. Did you ever see the movie Open Water? No. What was the one? Isn't that Nicole Kidman? Yeah, Nicole Kidman, Sam Neill. No, that was... What was that one from years ago?
开放水域，甚至看像那些电影的人。你看过电影《开放水域》吗？没有。那是哪一部？那不是妮可·基德曼演的吗？是的，妮可·基德曼，山姆·尼尔。不，那是……那是多年前的那部什么电影？
Below Deck. Dead Calm. Below Deck. On Bravo. Oh, it's Below Deck. Yes, B-E-L. I thought it was Below, okay. Sorry, it was a different show.
《甲板之下》。《死亡平静》。《甲板之下》。在Bravo频道。噢，是《甲板之下》。是的，B-E-L。我以为是Below，好的。抱歉，那是另一个节目。
It's about a guy I dated named Dick. All right, so, no, but Open Water, the movie, did you ever see the movie Open Water? It's based on a true story about the scuba divers. And the scuba divers all go down and they all come back up and the boat counters like, okay, this couple's back, this couple's back, and the boat takes off and they leave a couple in the ocean
那是关于我约会过的一个叫迪克的家伙。好吧，所以，不，但《开放水域》，那部电影，你看过电影《开放水域》吗？它是根据真实故事改编的，关于那些水肺潜水员。水肺潜水员都下去了，他们都上来了，船上的人数了一下，好的，这对夫妇回来了，这对夫妇回来了，然后船就开走了，他们把一对夫妇留在了海洋里，
underneath snorkeling still or whatever, and they come up and they fucking, they're in the middle of open water. Rude, it's just rude. That's right, anyways. And what do they do? What happens, Sean? They get, of course, they meet their demise
还在下面浮潜什么的，他们上来后，他们他妈的，他们就在开放水域的中间。粗鲁，这简直太粗鲁了。没错，不管怎样。他们做了什么？发生了什么，肖恩？他们当然，他们迎来了他们的死亡，
by sharks and everything. Truly? Yeah. I think it's based on a true story. I met people on that thing. How do they know? How do they know what happened? Oh, how terrible.
被鲨鱼什么的。真的吗？是的。我想它是根据真实故事改编的。我见过那件事里的人。他们怎么知道？他们怎么知道发生了什么？噢，太可怕了。
So you sit there, you watch them bobbing in the ocean for an hour and a half, and then they get eaten, and you can go ahead, roll credits? It's based on a true story. I met people on it. How do they know? How do they know what happened? Oh, how terrible. So you sit there, you watch them bobbing in the ocean for an hour and a half, and then they get eaten, and you can go ahead and roll credits? Yes, but it's like, it's really intense. It's really scary. Wow. Anyway.
所以你就坐在那里，看着他们在海洋里浮浮沉沉一个半小时，然后他们被吃了，然后你就可以直接放演职员表了？它是根据真实故事改编的。我见过那件事里的人。他们怎么知道？他们怎么知道发生了什么？噢，太可怕了。所以你就坐在那里，看着他们在海洋里浮浮沉沉一个半小时，然后他们被吃了，然后你就可以直接放演职员表了？是的，但这就像，它真的很紧张。它真的很吓人。哇。不管怎样。
I could skip that. How did they have the time to write the screenplay before they died? Because if they say it's a true story, how the fuck do we know? They had an iPhone. They had an iPhone. Nice try.
我可以跳过那个。他们在死前怎么有时间写剧本的？因为如果他们说是真实故事，我们他妈的怎么知道？他们有iPhone。他们有iPhone。想得美。
Nice try. Nice try. But thank God Daisy Ridley is all good from the Black Sea and nothing happened to her. But anyway. So who's working on a bi? I mean I think everybody's always working on a bi. But don't ask why. Everybody's working on a bi. And then...
想得美。想得美。但谢天谢地，黛西·雷德利在黑海一切安好，她没出什么事。但不管怎样。那么谁在做传记片？我是说我觉得每个人总是在做传记片。但别问为什么。每个人都在做传记片。然后……
Since the dawn of time. You know where I read it? I read it in the Bible. Bible. Nice, we've never used that. Amen. Bible, Bible. Smart.
自古以来。你知道我在哪读到的吗？我在《圣经》里读到的。《圣经》。不错，我们从没用过那个。阿门。《圣经》，《圣经》。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjarff, Bennett Barbicoe, and Michael Grant Terry. If you like SmartList, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey.
Less。聪明。Less。SmartLess是由罗伯·阿姆贾夫、本内特·巴比科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里手工制作的100%有机艺术品。如果你喜欢SmartLess，你可以现在加入Wondery App或Apple Podcasts上的Wondery Plus，提前收听无广告版本。Prime会员可以在Amazon Music上收听无广告版本。在你离开之前，请在Wondry.com/survey填写一份简短的调查问卷，告诉我们关于你的信息。
Scammers are best known for living the high life until they're forced to trade it all in for handcuffs and an orange jumpsuit once they're finally caught. I'm Saatchi Cole. And I'm Sarah Haggye. And we're the host of Scamfluencers, a weekly podcast from Wondery that takes you along the twists and turns of some of the most infamous scams of all time,
骗子们最出名的是过着奢华的生活，直到他们最终被抓获，被迫用这一切换取手铐和橙色连体衣。我是萨奇·科尔。我是莎拉·哈吉。我们是Wondery每周播客《Scamfluencers》的主持人，带你领略史上最臭名昭著的骗局的曲折离奇，
the impact on victims, and what's left once the facade falls away. We've covered stories like a Shark Tank certified entrepreneur who left the show with an investment, but soon faced mounting bills, an active lawsuit filed by Larry King, and no real product to push. He then began to prey on vulnerable women instead, selling the idea of a future together while stealing from them behind their backs.
对受害者的影响，以及当伪装剥落后留下了什么。我们报道过像一位获得“创智赢家”认证的企业家这样的故事，他带着投资离开了节目，但很快面临堆积如山的账单、拉里·金提起的活跃诉讼，以及没有真正的产品可推销。他随后开始转而猎捕弱势女性，兜售在一起的未来的想法，同时在背后窃取她们的钱财。
To the infamous scams of Real Housewives stars like Teresa Giudice, what should have proven to be a major downfall only seemed to solidify her place in the Real Housewives Hall of Fame. Follow Scamfluencers on the Wendree app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to Scamfluencers early and ad-free right now on Wendree+. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
到像特蕾莎·朱迪斯这样的《比弗利娇妻》明星的臭名昭著的骗局，本应被证明是一次重大失败的事情，似乎反而巩固了她在《比弗利娇妻》名人堂中的地位。在Wondery App或任何你获取播客的地方关注《Scamfluencers》。你现在可以在Wondery+上提前收听无广告版的《Scamfluencers》。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。